okay can you hear me now I turned that
mic down on the desk here that helps yep
um we've been waiting for our clerk to
arrive she's not here yet but uh we're
not supposed to start any of these
hearings until about 9 15. what I had
set up when I will read this script at
that time but for committee members
I wanted to explain the procedure in
which we're going to rule through these
bills today we'd only have three bills
SB 44 147 and 148. two of those are
Omnibus bills and when we're looking at
that
um I think it'd be appropriate that when
we're going through for example and
starting on 147 where there are are four
parts to that bill
that we will discuss part one and
anybody who wants to testify in part one
can do so at that time
then we'll close down part two one and
go into part two there that way we won't
be jumping around through this bill and
it'll be very difficult for us to and
for folks that want to testify too to
listen to other people on this
particular aspect of the bill
so if there's no objections from the
committee I'd like to just take it down
by the parts uh and the same thing for
148 where we have five parts there and
and all the parts are basically within
the realm of education but they are all
very very different so
um it's almost like four bills and one
and five bills in the other so let's go
buy the part and we'll we'll do that
um in the meantime here
um I'm working on some of the retained
bills trying to figure out subcommittee
work that we'll be doing on retained
bills we've been given the green light
to go ahead with uh our subcommittee
work on retained bills uh following this
meeting I'm going to sit down here and
and try to look at which ones we might
combine and work uh in the in one
particular subcommittee group and I'll
get back to members uh on the committee
in terms of appointing people to the
various subcommittee uh committees that
we're going to have to have
um other than that I know uh we're
basically now waiting for the Senate to
go through a number of the bills which
we have submitted to them there was
hearings yesterday on five lowest bills
they're working on it so I urge all to
be looking at the center calendar and
staying attuned to what is going on here
so you have the opportunity to
testify in the Senate
so I'm gonna wait about seven minutes
here seven eight minutes before we we
start at 9 15.
um I'm waiting also for our clerk to
arrive
so
um let's just take a breather get a cup
of coffee and I know some of you been
waiting a while as this but uh are there
is there any other
um information that anybody on the
committee would like to ask at this time
this is kind of like an informal session
for the first 15 minutes by the way we
will not be accepting any bills today
we will not exact any bills today
Mr chair I have a question yeah I was
just wondering how uh I am going to
determine who wants to speak to what
part of the bill I will explain it when
we okay open up every hearing I will
explain how we're going to Wade through
this so that then the persons that want
to speak on part one they can push the
flag up with their hand up and we can
rent okay
and we'll take them in the order that
they signed up
I think that could you promote me
foreign
mellow out
ah mellow out I am
I don't let it stay with me
[Music]
Mr chair yes
do I remember right on Omnibus bills
it's we vote for everything's included
we can't say we like them all except
part three or whatever it's it's
everything correct when when we look at
an Omnibus Bill the final product can be
what we amend to it we can take uh items
out we can put items in but we have
different rules in the Senate our our
additions to any Bill have to be germane
yeah
that particular part or that any part of
that bill so
um yes at the final final work if we
amend anything the whole bill will be
amended okay
um to reflect that change because we're
going to be voting at the end on Senate
[Music]
as at this point for folks that are out
there we have
uh people that are signed up to
testifying these bills
um how many do we have uh Deb on the
first one or one step seven seven on the
first bill that's 44. of course there
could be others that sign in as we go
on on the second Bill 147 147 is another
seven people
and and the last bill it's more 11 on
the last bill as of last night when I
talked with Gen 4 we had five five and
foreign
[Music]
are you enjoying it
it's nice down huh
thanks
I had Tony cut exactly four inches off I
gave him a ruler and the scissors and I
said four inches exactly
drop into this one
is
this one
we've got two clocks and three clocks in
this room
here
um
thank you
so at least you have your
[Music]
my lunch I was gonna make this morning
and then I didn't end up having time and
I had gotten all these wonderful
everyone make it last night
foreign
misunderstood when I said large green
leaves I didn't care whether it was
collard greens or notice the difference
and use it instead of red yeah so then I
thought well I guess I can use the roast
thank you so I guess and I guess to
virus
all right
foreign
[Music]
that looks to be about it that I
recognized
ergonomics no video
yeah probably has children running
around
[Music]
I actually got back from dropping the
kids off for the day so I'm by myself
it's fantastic
don't tell anybody okay it's 9 15 so I
think it's time to open up this hearing
so I'll read the Chairman's script for
the committee and then
um explain how we're gonna approach
these bills today uh welcome to
everybody in the public and members of
the committee uh to Senate education of
course House Education
as chair of the House Education
committee I find that that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of covid-19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
this is a public hearing of bills
referred to the education committee
executive session on pending legislation
may be held I will say right now that
there will be no executive session
following uh the hearing today
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting applies with
house rules and RSA 91-8 anyone who has
a problem accessing the meeting should
call
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
I want to introduce the staff that are
are helping us assisting and assisting
US during this meeting we have Jennifer
for our committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote let's start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also State whether there's anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to no
law
okay
like we don't want to hear any grills or
anything
folks let's let the clerk take care of
this
representative cordelli
yeah
representative Allen here in the
committee room representative here in
the committee room representative
Moffett
representative Austin here in the
committee well
from Center of address and she's not
still muted there you go here here in my
home office in Chester alone thank you
Senator lay on
home alone and dairy I will be turning
off the camera from time to time because
[Music]
here in my home office in Kentucky by
myself
here
yes
Paul Malone in Manchester
Tanner
uh home alone in Georges Mills and my
dog may bark
Amir Heath here subbing for art Ellison
today and I'm here in Manchester Home
Alone welcome to the committee Mary
thank you
Mary
write this down for it yeah
from Senator Mullen here in the basement
in Bedford
right
I am here in Jaffrey New Hampshire and I
am alone
representative Woodcock here in Santa
Claus New Hampshire with my barking
Dirty Dog Brady and my wife
Unleash Your Wife stopped barking
oh yeah
representative black I'm here in the
thank you thank you very much everybody
um for members of the public uh when we
get into all the the bills uh that we
have today which are three SB 44 SB 147
and SB 148. the latter two have
um various parts to them uh they're
Omnibus bills one has four parts one has
five parts when we have testimony
offered to us I'm going to ask that
people speak to the part that we're
addressing for example when we get to
147 today uh there are no parts but one
yes there are four parts there are four
parts wheel type part one and folks that
have want to give testimony referencing
part one that's when you will have the
opportunity if you also have information
for us on part two hold that and we will
discuss that have you present on part
two at that time you may have something
for three or may not have for three so
we'll work through it that way that way
we will not be jumping around from one
part to another part and folks will be
able to all hear the questions in the
testimony referencing uh specific parts
of the bills so with that I'm going to
open up the uh hearing for Senate Bill
44 this is a bill establishing the New
Hampshire Workforce pathway program
the prime sponsor of the bill is Senator
Jay Khan uh I believe Jay may have
gotten in late from Chicago uh he
attended a family activity out there
over the weekend
um and I spoke with him and
it uh I don't see him and I don't
believe we have others that are
the administrative assistant for our
um so uh what I will do is I will
introduce the bill simply identifying
the bill simply just not getting into
the any other rational or content or the
intent of the bill and then we'll start
taking testimony
uh and and Senator Khan asked me to
introduce it for him if he's not here so
my name is Rick Ladd I am a co-sponsor
of the bill I come from Haverhill New
Hampshire and I'm here today to
introduce Senate bill 44. Senate Bill 44
is a bill that deals when establishes a
Workforce pathway program and Community
College system of New Hampshire
with that I'm going to
um finish my testimony and open this up
to
others who may be signed up to testify
okay are you ready for that first
Speaker yes okay first Speaker uh is
Anne-Marie
go ahead
okay great can you hear me
yeah oh perfect
um so my name is Ian Ray Banfield I'm an
advocate for parental rights and
academic excellence in education I come
here in opposition of SB 44. I was not
able to testify an sb44 when it was
introduced in the Senate but since then
I have given this a lot of thought and
uh looked over the bill closely and have
decided to speak before the house
education committee
roughly 20 years ago the federal
government pushed the school to work
initiative
it was considered a fad at that time and
quickly dissolved because it didn't have
anything to do with students natural
desires or what their parents wanted for
them
it had to do with focusing on the needs
of the employers and providing them
labor students would be tracked into the
vocation that the government determined
was essential for employers that's not
student-centered focused
those of you who are familiar with Mark
Tucker knows that he spelled all of this
out in his famous letter to Hillary
Clinton during the Clinton presidency
Tucker's Vision was for public schools
to become a development resource system
for employers and he continues that
mission today
so they came up with student learning
Pathways that would be developed for
career Pathways early on until students
graduated from high school and into
college and Beyond
so Texas law today for instance requires
students to choose a pathway in seventh
grade
did you know what you wanted to do in
seventh grade
this is tied to the Common Core National
Standards Initiative which is a
Workforce Development model in education
the model is not focused on academic
outcomes or literacy but Workforce
training and skills
and the 1991 report the secretary's
Commission on achieving necessary skills
helped change the direction of the
nation's schools from knowledge-based
academic content into an education
philosophy where the emphasis is on
emotions opinions beliefs and with an
emphasis on workplace competencies when
competency-based education was
introduced to this committee I sat in on
those hearings and opposed the
legislation requiring CB
competency-based education
to be implemented in all public schools
and I recall chairman Ladd and I believe
representative Shah serving on the house
education committee at that time there
was a great deal of discussion over
competencies that could measure student
dispositions it was clear to me and
there would seemed to be consensus among
Representatives that competencies would
not be used in a way to measure a
student's disposition
Democrats and Republicans agreed on us
the focus of competencies were to be to
be used to measure academics and skills
skills that would benefit the students
as they prog progressed and would help
them in life like time management and
collaboration for instance
but now we have social emotional
competencies that measure dispositions
because sb44 requires this program to be
based on competencies I cannot support
it without defining competencies as
academic or limiting competencies to
specific skills what will students
college students be measured on
will it be on their attitudes on
political issues will it be on their
emotions this program is part of
attracting students from pre-k to the
workforce envisioned by unelected
bureaucrats pushing public education
away from Liberal Arts model towards a
Workforce training model
in addition there are no Provisions to
protecting student privacy and sb44
competencies are now shared with
colleges when students apply high school
students
sb44 makes no provision for consent by
the student to share competencies with
another institution or a future employer
I listen to a conversation between the
Department of Education and CTE
coordinators coordinators around New
Hampshire roughly probably about a year
and a half ago
one coordinator talked about how to get
more students into the service industry
because that's where the jobs are that
is not a focus on what is best for
students that is a focus on what is best
for employers if students are choosing
career paths based on the needs of
employers what does that look like long
term what happens if their chosen career
becomes obsolete
there was even a discussion on how long
the students stay in these jobs someone
suggested that some don't stay past one
year
when SB within sb44 the language
indicates that the purpose is to focus
on meeting the needs of the business
that is not student focused that is in
section 2
um part A if you look at the if you look
at the language
in another section it says that there's
no cost to participants well that's
because this is will be paid for by
federal tax dollars what happens when
the federal feds cut the funding who
um in the notes from the Senate hearing
Senator Bradley expressed concern for
federal funding ending uh Dr Susan
whoard Chancellor for the community
college system responded but did not
provide a definitive statement on when
those funds would expire and who would
be in charge of replacing that funding
she mentioned that the that currently
crrsa would be used to provide funding
crrsa funding is based on emergency
funding due to the pandemic at some
point that funding will most likely end
and who is Le and we are left to spec
speculate on who will be left to pick up
um chancellor who had also said that
there would be adequate funding for at
least the next few years but again that
we are left to speculate
within sb44 it also talks about this is
that the resources will come from
federal the federal Workforce
opportunity investment Act
we can no longer rely on FERPA to re to
protect personal Privacy Information due
to the regulatory changes
how a student personally identified
information be shared with the federal
government how will they then share this
information for instance in FERPA to
assist research studies allows
non-consensual redisclosure disclosure
of personally identified
identifiable information that was
provided by certain educational agencies
and institutions to other such agencies
and institutions the lack of privacy
Protections in this legislation needs to
be scrutinized since competencies now
expand into measuring attitudes and
values how will these competencies be
shared will future employers now have
access in addition to to the certificate
awarded the U.S Department of Education
can now share information with the
Department of Labor due to the
regulatory changes in FERPA
there is nothing in this legislation
that directs the Community College to
require students to review and consent
for the release of all competencies that
will be shared if they apply to another
I will send you a copy of a letter that
was said to the United States Department
of Education sharing serious concerns
regarding the proposed rule changes to
FERPA this letter was signed by the
executive director from the American
Association of Collegiate Collegiate
registrars and admission officers the
letter was sent
and because of the alarming changes to
FERPA
and it highlights the Nullification of
they go on to say they say this
in reviewing the regulatory changes
proposed by the department we are
alarmed by several striking factors
first the proposed changes represent a
wholesale repudiation of fair
information practices well-settled
principles of notice consent access
participation data minimization and data
retention all undermined by the Paradigm
Shift promoted by this proposal
um in in order to get through this
quickly I will allow you to read the
rest of it I will send that to you and
not belabor that point but that is uh
um the lack of language addressed
addressing is the need to protect these
kinds of data should prevent anyone from
from supporting this legislation I would
certainly encourage you to read their
letter this is from the college
system itself
in addition according to Senate notes
from sb44 Senator French suggested a
sense that Provisions since the sponsor
Senator Khan mentioned that this type of
training is needed during the covet
pandemic when federal funds run out who
picks up the tab a sunset Amendment
seems like a logical
Chancellor Howard also mentioned the
potential to move to to the use of
digital badges
these are digital badges that will
eventually replace competencies again
nothing about protecting the privacy of
the students digital badges or consent
to release the information
has anyone looked to see if these
certificates would qualify a student for
a transfer to a university or college
there's nothing in a language that
includes any follow-up with employers to
see if the graduates are properly
trained for the money that we are about
to spend on training them
nothing in the language indicates that
this program will be analyzed in any way
for Effectiveness it will be federal
dollars but that is still taxpayer
funding at some point State funds could
be required
finally I'm just about done finally
votech and trade schools have been
available in the past for students who
want to seek an alternative pathway they
were chosen by students with a focus on
what is best for that student that's how
we go back to a student-centered focus
this lessens the chance of spending
money on a vocation that they may walk
away from from after a short time after
completing it
when a government program is funded by
the government and focused on the needs
of the business how long will these
graduates continue in their chosen
profession
should there be skill in the game by
those utilizing this program so they are
more likely to take it seriously when
education institutions become a vehicle
for employers will they lose the focus
on what is best for the student from the
discussion with the CTE coordinators
that is a definite possibility while
employers can certainly be a a resource
this redesign in public education is a
complete paradigm shift to a Workforce
Workforce model
this is part of that model this program
is another step towards the Seamless Web
envisioned by Mark Tucker it is similar
to track it to the tracking system in
European countries and it should be
noted that you won't see students
finishing at the top on International
tests in math and science in those
countries I would suggest that this
legislation be turned into a study
committee where all of this can be
discussed and more is this what New
Hampshire residents want for their
children or is this a vision of Mark
Tucker who who most New Hampshire people
wouldn't even be able to recognize job
preparation is important for sure but
that cannot come at the expense of
literacy and it cannot come at the
expense of looking out for the
well-being of the students in our
education system so for these reasons I
urge you to vote itl and sb44 thank you
thank you very much Miss Banfield are
you willing to take any questions
if you have time I suppose yes
are there any questions
not seeing any hands up thank you very
let's go ahead miss you welcome
Chancellor
are you there you
can muted
I am I am thank you representative black
good morning everyone I'm here to speak
uh in support of SB 44 establishing the
New Hampshire Workforce pathway program
when Senator Khan and other folks
created this it is modeled after a very
successful program in the state of
Virginia
and I thought I would address a few of
the questions that have come up uh
during the Senate phase of the bill
which ultimately passed uh the first
question was is this also a request for
funding
while in the original Bill there was
some suggestions about finding the
current bill this is not a request for
funding because we believe that the
funding source is already exist uh there
as uh the previous speaker mentioned
wioa funds are available uh there will
be short-term pal regular Pell which is
being increased there are scholarship
opportunities from entities like the New
Hampshire automobile dealers and and so
on so we think that there is money
available for these short-term training
programs for in-demand jobs
we're talking about people who have
already been graduated from high school
and are in the workforce or just
entering the workforce this is entirely
about short-term training as a launch
pad for the next step that an individual
may wish to take
you might have the question of you know
since there are organizations that
already do this is the bill really
needed one of the challenges is in fact
the the silos that exist within our
government
and various non-profits including our
colleges and so our interest in this
particular commission is that all of us
will sit in one room
and that you know oftentimes a
commission is what causes the parties to
focus around the table for the community
college system there are many
opportunities that are coming under the
Biden Administration in terms of Grants
uh at one point in New Hampshire's
history we were very attractive to
Grants because we were seen as a
prototype for the largest states well
that has changed and now we frequently
lose out on grant opportunities to
larger entities like Florida and Texas
and California
one of the ways for us to indicate to
these grantors
our interest is to have all of us
together in a commission and to be able
to cite within our applications that
everyone that has something to do with
Workforce Development is sitting in the
um I thank you again for your
consideration of sb44 I'd be happy to
answer any questions that you might have
thank you very much Chancellor are there
questions for Susan Huard yes
representative cordelli thank you thank
you
getting everybody together because there
is no permission but I see in this
uh legislation so I'm wondering what
mission you are
um referring to
uh perhaps I'm using the wrong word by
uh describing it as a commission but a a
a a group wherein we have members of
various state agencies uh and members of
various non-profits including the
Community College sitting together
discussing the workforce needs of the
state and the opportunities for
short-term funding for those
bills
thank you
thank you are there further questions
for yes representative luno thank you
very much Mr chair and thank you
Chancellor for uh for joining us this
morning
um I was wondering if you could talk
with us just a little bit about
um how uh Pell Grants might be
applicable to
um
um uh to for folks that may be taking
less than a full-time
uh you know course load in order to get
a uh you know a high value credential
built you know build a high value
credential sure thank you for the
question representative currently
um students who are PAL eligible can
either attend as full-time students or
as part-time students but those funds
right now are directed towards
certificates that are at least 16
college credits or more or full-fledged
degrees such as the associate degrees
offered by the community college system
what the government is currently
contemplating they've completed a pilot
on funding for short-term training
programs so these would be things that
are less than six months and are not
necessarily credit bearing so as that
moves from Pilot stage to full-fledged
implementation will have an opportunity
to help students and residents to um
fund their you know participation in for
example L A programs basic automotive
technician uh there are in other states
opportunities for people who are in the
information technology area to become
coders with short programs so it's
funding that has not been available and
is very likely to be available shortly
thank you that's that's excellent
Chancellor thanks very much very good
news representative
uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
Chancellor for being with us this
morning so my understanding is is that
this uh bill would try to identify
short-term opportunities for individuals
to get certificates this is not focused
necessarily on a degree program but more
a certificate program that an individual
may say I might want to do this based
upon my current uh personal situation to
try to advance myself into the workforce
is that correct yes uh representative
Miler that's absolutely correct this is
in fact not aimed at all at degrees and
in terms of certificates it is only
aimed at short-term certificates so for
example this is not aimed at people who
might want to be a licensed practical
nurses but it is aimed at helping people
who would like to take the very first
step as an LNA to help them fund what is
a couple thousand dollars whether they
come through the community college
system or some of the private nonprofits
that also run those programs so this is
that first step
um when the bill was being conceived we
were thinking about the people who have
been unemployed particularly those in
retail industries that and in
Hospitality that have lost their
positions in conversations with
individuals we hear that they would like
to look at other fields where perhaps
the you know the the employee women is
more secure so this is a help to them to
move them into that very first step and
obviously from our point of view we hope
that they will move through certificates
and degrees not only with us but also at
the Baccalaureate level
thank you for the clarification thank
you sir
thank you uh representative woodcock
thank you Mr chairman Chancellor thank
you so much for uh explaining more about
this this bill much appreciated I just
uh my question
uh deals specifically with law
enforcement is there any chance that the
Community College will be working with
them in terms of uh preparation as we
know many of the police forces around
the state currently have vacancies and
and uh I didn't know helping students
prepare for the criminal justice program
or work activity
um well representative that hasn't I
haven't heard anything about that yet
but we tend to uh you know follow where
the employment needs are and if that is
an area uh we certainly have several uh
colleges that have uh criminal justice
programs and working with them to
identify what the preliminary skill set
could be that is something I could
easily take to the various advisory
committees to see uh what we could
figure out uh one of the things that we
have spoken about is the community
college system is uh
is beginning to use badges
um and these are something that an
individual can choose to display on his
or her resume but what a badges is it
says that you've you've got this
particular set of skills it may be in
working with law enforcement that we can
identify a specific set of skills that
would lead to that first job so we
certainly would be interested
thank you thank you so much for your
response and thank you for taking the
time to speak with us today thank you
very much
rep sound like
thank you Mr chairman and thank you uh
Chancellor for taking the question
um my question just concerns who is
eligible for this program according to
the language of the bill it's the uh
unemployed and underemployed New
Hampshire adults and then more
specifically the pathway program shall
provide training to furloughed laid off
dislocated underserved or other
populations affected by covet 19. so is
this a limited program limited to those
populations because I'm sort of hearing
there seems almost like this assumption
that anybody can apply for this but
that's my reading of the bill is that's
not the case at all
thank you representative
um
you know we always try to include uh
people who are interested so while this
this bill is specifically aimed at the
underemployed and the unemployed on
account of covid and frankly that's the
way some of the uh grants that we expect
to be eligible for is worded those are
the primary people we would serve but uh
we always leave the door open a little
bit for other folks but they are not the
primary audience the primary audience is
exactly as you've described them sir
thank you
thank you very much uh Chancellor heward
I have a question for you just trying to
understand uh some of the wording in the
bill a little bit
um currently within the Department of
Business and economic Affairs the office
of Workforce opportunity works with
programs and partners to provide these
Workforce training opportunities and
training that we're talking about I
understand within the combined state
plan the community college system is
currently a member that apartment that
works towards this endeavor
um then in looking at the bill in Romans
3 at the very base of the bill bill just
before the effective date
it says
um partner with the Department of
Employment Security Department of
Economic Affairs director of Workforce
Development and Career Technical
education centers
how is this bill going to be more
effective than the present format that
we have here in the state through the
Department of Business and economic
Affairs going to improve our preparation
of these people and need to be retooled
or trained in another another field
thank you representative Ladd I guess I
would say that
um what's called for in this bill would
enhance the pre-existing
organizations
um my understanding of the office of
Workforce opportunity and and their
um management of wioa there are only
specific uh certificates that qualify
for wioa but there are other
possibilities
that we would like to explore so I my
short answer is that this broadens the
work and and includes more entities than
that which is specified in wioa
thank you are there further questions
for the chancellor
uh Rex and cordelli yes thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you uh Chancellor
again
um you mentioned
um the uh use of digital factors I
believe
um and I'm just wondering if that is a
system developed by the community
college system or if you're using a
third-party vendor for that
um and maybe any additional information
you could provide to this uh committee
or especially myself I would appreciate
I'm I'm sorry representative are you
saying digital badging I I can't quite
hear you oh okay all right
um so additional information
um
we have uh a committee across College
committee that's working on this we have
um adopted a a badging product called
badger in fact
um a few weeks ago president Larissa
baia from Lakes Region Community College
announced the first badge
um and that is being awarded to a people
uh working in restaurants
um there was a short-term training
program that was developed between the
Restaurant Association and three of our
community colleges White Mountains Lakes
Region and I believe the third one was
Nashua and
um in in working with these individuals
put together
um it's kind of a safety certification
so that people were behaving
appropriately in terms of food handling
and and treatment of guests and so on we
worked with the common man restaurants
as well
and batching is a way of capturing a
particular set of skills and they're
actually embedded in the badge itself so
that individuals can post this on their
resume if they so choose as they're
looking for future employment
this is a relatively new activity for us
and we're looking at whether this
translates in any way into college
credit we think likely some of them will
and we need to as an organization build
a structure around that but at this
moment the community college system is
working on badging within our Workforce
training and non-credit area I can
certainly send you more information
about the product that we are using I
would also say that the universe city of
New Hampshire in their extension
program has also begun to issue badges
as a way of collecting information
we are I guess we're kind of in the
middle of this effort other states are
certainly ahead of us in fact this
original badge that we came up with was
based on conversations that I had with
colleagues in Texas who had put together
a similar program and began to speak
with us about the value to individuals
thank you very much
Chancellor I have one further question
um
the the program that's being recommended
in SBE 44 is going to be coordinated
with various types of programs like
Department of Employment Security what
is the meaning of Education agencies are
you talking about the Department of
Education seeing we're also referencing
prayer technical education I'm just
trying to figure out where the
Department of Education comes into play
in this bill
I I suspect it would be on the CTE side
of things representative lad uh we were
not envisioning something larger uh such
as that which was uh described by the
previous speaker there are some uh
comprehensive high schools that have
spoken with us about what kind of
activity could happen this summer after
graduation so I do anticipate that we
may have conversations with
Comprehensive high schools that are
interested in addition to the ctes
um I I honestly don't expect that that's
the large part of this audience though
we expect that it is unemployed people
dislocated people under employed people
that are the uh the focus at this point
thank you very much uh are there further
questions for Chancellor here
not see any hands up thank you very much
thank you sir I appreciate the help and
I do hope that you will vote to pass SB
Carpenter
endless
good morning
can you hear me yes we can okay thank
you very much
um I'm also here to speak uh in favor of
sb44 I am the program director for a
grant funded program called New
Hampshire needs caregivers it's funded
through civil monetary penalty funds to
recruit and train 700 licensed nursing
assistants to work in New Hampshire
nursing homes
over the past year of my program New
Hampshire needs caregivers I've had over
700 individuals reach out to me
interested in a career in health care
specifically as a licensed nursing
assistant
there's a great desire for a career in
health care
the barriers right now include access to
training in different locations of the
state and also access to financial
resources
I've also found that individuals looking
to start a career in healthcare need
some coaching and support and I'm sure
as you all know or have heard numerous
times probably there is certainly a need
for additional caregivers in New
Hampshire we have an aging population
the average age of our nursing staff is
approaching retirement age so we
certainly need more entry-level workers
I'm reiterating the statement that made
by Chancellor heward the benefits to
sb44 really are to reduce the silos and
establish a program for collaboration to
develop a Workforce strategy to define
the issues and develop meaningful and
effective actions to meet the workforce
needs of the state
personally I worked as a nursing home
administrator for over 20 years
retiring from that career about a year
ago and I can tell you in my own
experience there's always been a need
for for caregivers I've also worked with
several entry-level caregivers who
really want opportunities for growth and
for those reasons I ask that you vote in
favor of sb44
thank you very much Miss Carpenter are
there questions
not seeing any hands thank you very much
for your testimony thank you for your
uh thank you Mr chairman I trust
everyone can hear me okay yes we can
thank you for the record my name is Dave
Juve I'm a senior vice president with
the business and industry Association we
are New Hampshire's Statewide Chamber of
Commerce we are here in support of SB 44
and my purpose is to convey to the
committee the uh critical urgency of
Workforce needs with employers across
the state and I have to confess even
though I work on economic development
and Workforce Development issues it came
as a little bit of a surprise to me
um we over the past week several weeks
have been begun hearing from employers
from all sectors of the economy on their
difficulty in finding a Workforce and I
say it took me a little bit by surprise
because obviously we're still in the
middle of the uh coronavirus pandemic
and employers went a year ago from being
concerned about Workforce to being
concerned about staying in business
but that has changed dramatically and we
know that the state's unemployment rate
is uh approaching pre-pandemic uh
unemployment which was among the lowest
in the nation and we are hearing from
our members uh that that uh Workforce is
again becoming their most critical issue
so
um I would encourage the committee to
look favorably on this bill it will
assist in programs that already are
happening in the state like these sector
Partnerships and the programs through
the office of business and economic
Affairs
um referred to by the previous
speakers uh this will better prepare
those who are unemployed and
underemployed for the types of jobs that
are readily available right now in New
Hampshire and
um frankly unlike a lot of legislation I
see no negatives with this one but only
positive so thank you Mr chair members
of the committee I'd be happy to answer
any questions thank you very much Mr
jubay I'm sorry for butchering your your
last name
it's not the first time that's ever
happened Mr chair okay thank you uh are
thanks very much Mr chair and thanks uh
Mr Juve for uh joining us this morning
um just a couple of quick questions uh
just wondering what um um what
organization develops the um the sort of
the is there a list of um of critical
Workforce shortage areas or Workforce
needs
uh that's an excellent question uh
representative Luna so thanks for
answering I can only respond based on
what I'm hearing from our members and I
should say the Bia covers a wide
spectrum of uh businesses and you know
covering all areas of the economy we are
we have less members in the retail
sector the auto dealerships and
restaurants especially because they have
their own associations and do a great
job but we cover uh manufacturing
business services financial services and
we run the gamut uh use utilities Public
Utilities we run the gamut from the
state's largest companies down to sole
Proprietors so I can only tell you what
I'm hearing and what I'm hearing right
now is especially coming from the
manufacturing sector where they are
finding it almost impossible to fill
open positions let alone find people
that are well qualified
so and a follow-up on that Mr chair
so um so thanks and and so the the
follow-up question really is really sort
of focuses in on the manufacturing
sector but uh but it it it's it's really
it's I I think this has been developing
for several years now in this you know
acute Workforce shortage uh issue is um
you know tends to be a double-edged
sword when it comes to Workforce
training as well because it means
there's fewer people uh available
um let's say for instance at the
community college level to um to staff
these these courses in um you know
whether it's engineering technology and
I was wondering if if maybe uh Senate
Bill might Senate Bill 44 if it doesn't
already could could help to um
um extend the Partnerships between the
the private sector and the and for
example the community college system to
to make sure that um
that the community colleges are staffed
appropriately in order to to
um you know have instructure instructors
to for the curriculum that's uh that's
really necessary uh to meet the
workforce needs yeah representative Lino
I think those connections exist but I
think Senate Bill 44 will strengthen and
expand those connections I would say
that a lot of the positions that are
open now in manufacturing
um I'm sure there are some that are
highly technical but many of these
positions are those that are considered
entry level and so what what employers
are looking for is people with basic
computer skills and literacy skills I I
was I guess a little amused by a
previous testifier saying that literacy
and I'm paraphrasing but literacy you
know wasn't important to employers and I
I just was somewhat mystified by that
because that's a basic competency that
any employer is looking for so
um the direct anterior question is I
think those connections exist but I
think Senate Bill 44 will be very
helpful in strengthening and expanding
those connections great fantastic thank
you David
thank you very much uh Mr duvet further
questions
representative Leon uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you Mr Juve for taking
the question I have been speaking with
Employers in my area and a lot of their
needs are actually based on people not
wanting to go back to work because
they're receiving stimulus funds and
other funds that that mean that they
don't actually have to re-enter the
workforce is that something you've
spoken to uh members of the Bia and have
you seen how much that's impacting them
versus training issues yeah this is a a
little off topic but I would like to
respond Mr chair with your permission
um there are uh those in our membership
who are concerned about that issue
they're also concerned about because of
covid-19 there was a waiver of the job
search requirement and that waiver
exists to this day the Bia this week
sent a letter to the governor urge and
to legislative leadership urging that
they rescind that waiver and and that
will help in some ways to get people
back to work
um I I think that's an issue I I don't
know that Senate Bill 44 would have a
direct impact on that but there are
certainly other issues relating to
Workforce that are that are out there
thank you thank you thank you very much
Mr Juve could you please uh forward a
copy that letter to the committee
I would be happy Mr chair should I send
it directly to you and staff for
distribution or send uh you can send it
to uh myself and I will distribute that
to all the committee members I will do
that before the end of the day thank you
Mr chair very much uh further questions
for Mr duvet
not seeing any thank you very much
I think Senator Khan is on the phone
I got that message from uh Senator Khan
and we're we're trying to connect with
okay he's doing so by telephones
first uh I need to press star six to
Senator Khan can you hear us
Facebook
foreign
yes are you in a plane on the ground in
Chicago or back in New Hampshire yeah
I can be quick Mr chairman and really
just respond if there are any questions
sounds like uh you there have been quite
a few supportive uh Partners to this
uh signed in with their testimony uh
and uh
I will say that in States like uh
Virginia and Utah
they began these efforts and they were
excellent
uh
yes we can
all right so the point was
uh this kind of uh alignment was
valuable when they had a Workforce
shortage
uh it then became valuable uh during the
pandemic as well as more people uh
needed to find their way with more
employable skills into the openings that
existed uh it's just a good vehicle to
uh put
the various pieces together and it
includes uh the Bea as a valuable
partner because
it's important for students who for
unemployed and underemployed people to
find their way into academic programs
but also to find their way to the
employers so that they get a vision of
what kind of training is going to be
once they enter that position in the
workforce uh and what's a job
opportunities for advancement and uh
initial starting salaries are going to
be and that really is where the
businesses come in and play a very
strong partnership role whether it's
with internships or or recruitment
information
um and then certainly the Bea plays such
an important role in keeping track of
the uh
labor economy in the state of New
Hampshire on a quarterly basis reporting
uh where the job needs are and updating
their projections so this the system of
alignment it it works uh and I think we
have the talent in this state to align
our resources uh in a very effective way
to assist uh
thank you very much Senator Khan Senator
Khan can you please explain to me and
the committee
a little bit more about the the the
source of funding that comes from the
federal Workforce Innovation and
Opportunity Act will that now be
funneled directly to the Community
College or is it still funneled through
the business and economic Affairs
Department
it absolutely is still with the Bea
what uh is a part of the Bea and the Bea
has some very good programs established
uh like employer-based training programs
uh which are really important as well as
as well as rapid re-employment
uh programs so uh but but I think this
is positioning ourselves for new dollars
coming into the state of New Hampshire
as well uh if you follow uh the current
federal Administration they do have uh
on the drawing boards uh how to use Pell
Grants to reduce the cost of certificate
programs and Rapid employment through
certificate programs in six month
periods
[Music]
I'm sorry Mr chairman
this has to be awkward
it's fine we understand are there are
there questions from the committee for
we're not seeing hands up uh Jay so uh
thank you very much and have a safe trip
home
thank you Mr chairman I wish this uh had
some pleasure connected to it but uh I'm
sorry for the family event that causes
me to not be able to be with you
thank you for your consideration
[Music]
next we have Dan Bennett
um
capture Auto Dealers Association welcome
to education Mr Bennett
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee can you hear me okay yes
we can we'd like to thank you very much
for what you do with the council for
Career Technical education
uh thank you for saying that it's our
pleasure
um I will be brief uh my name is Dan
Bennett from the New Hampshire
Automobile Dealers Association nhada is
a trade Association for the motor
vehicle industry in New Hampshire about
500 businesses we represent car truck
motorcycles snowmobile ATV
construction farm equipment Collision
Repair
um pretty much if it's got an engine and
tracks or Wheels we work with them so
um as mentioned we've got about 500
businesses in all corners of the State
uh in in all communities so we are here
in support of sp-44 and later on today I
will forward over our fact sheet and
testimony on this particular bill
we do work with the 20 high schools and
five colleges that have Automotive
Technical programs we work with them we
have for a long time uh very intensely
and we do a great deal of scholarship
work with students to get their career
started whether it's to help pay for
credits or uh help support maybe their
first set of tools
um not all folks know that a technician
who works at a dealership uh those are
actually their own tools that they pay
for out of their own pocket the the
business does not own them so we help
support that
um we believe that a homegrown uh local
Workforce is Key to Our Success it's why
we worked with the colleges and the high
school ctes for so long
um our two-year programs uh two-year
degree programs
um aren't for every everyone some folks
decide early on they want to work on a
General Motors car and they wind up in
Laconia for two years uh or Honda and
they want to be in Nashville and that's
what they've committed to but those
long-term commitments uh for both the
costs
um and also just you know interest level
aren't necessarily there and they don't
they don't fit for everyone so the bill
that Senator Khan has proposed and that
we've supported in the Senate as well
we kind of view it as it's an on-ramp
into our industry it's a short-term
offering to allow someone to get some
exposure uh to decide whether it's a
good fit for them and and and where it's
a good fit for them uh some folks may
have a have a a great interest in cars
um and and they're really fascinated
with them and it consumes them however
they just don't have the mechanical
aptitude to be deconstructing and
rebuilding them so uh maybe a better fit
for them is in the sales uh on the sales
force or maybe as a service writer maybe
the technician isn't right for them
maybe someone has a great interest in
business and marketing so they'll be in
our finance and insurance office or
Business Development Center maybe you're
very very organized so supply chain and
inventory management is your thing so
you find out that you're actually a
better fit for the parts department and
the wholesale parts business so
short-term programs like
um Senator Khan and SP 44 has proposed
allows this initial exposure to find
where and that best fit would be in our
industry and that's one of the reasons
why we will uh we do in fact support it
um we have an immediate need for a
variety of Workforce opportunities and
it's not just technicians
um we've got a clear need to fill those
those vacancies with a a talented and
committed and trained Workforce
um so that's the reason for our uh
support of this particular legislation
so
um again in uh in aiming to be brief I
want to uh re-echo our support for sp-44
hope that the committee can support it
um and give it a favorable
recommendation and I will um I'll
forward over my testimony as mentioned
and if possible I'll attempt to answer
any questions that you all may have
thank you very much Mr Bennett are there
questions for the Automobile Dealers
Association
uh Mr Bennett um
we have in this legislation that the
certificate completion has to be done in
not more than six months is six months
the appropriate time for these types of
programs do you need more time or can
you do it with six or less months
my understanding is that the the
legislation is based on a successful
model out of other states I believe
Virginia and Utah and so it has been
tested so I would assume that the the
sixth is acceptable you know it is
designed to be a short-term program so
that you can clearly decide do I want to
jump in for another two years or a year
and a half of schooling do I want to go
right out into the immediate Workforce
um and hope and be trained on the job
and have the employer hopefully support
it uh possibly through
um you know internal training offerings
that they may have internal mentorship
programs that they may have so my
understanding is that uh just to get
back to it that it is and that six month
uh does come from a tried and uh and and
tested program in other states so I
would assume that that's an appropriate
number
thank you very much further questions
from the committee not seeing any hands
up thank you very much Mr Bennett thank
you all have a great day
we we also for the committee we have the
uh technical people from the Department
of Education Steve Appleby uh available
if there's any questions for the
Department
not seeing any answer questions for the
thank you very much
all right is there anybody else so let's
see okay with that I'm going to close
the hearing for our Senate bill 44.
and we will enter into Senate bill for
147. Mr chair yes would you like to read
uh sure go ahead and read uh the
supporters are 33
opposed three
zero neutral and we were supposed to
have set a testify but I believe only
six did okay
yeah Senator Khan was yeah he was listed
uh we had a person who signed up to
seven side jobs
okay
yeah that's true
uh thank you very much uh there is
somebody with their hand out
for the next bill okay so we're going to
go in ahead and enter into Senate field
147 at this time this is a bill it's an
Omnibus Bill legislation relative to
student aid central registry
Transportation students and special
education costs
uh so it's one of those bills which
we've talked about at the beginning
where we're going to take it by Parts
we're going to go through the first part
first and notice that I have
um uh comments who want to testify in
the applications for federal student aid
uh they can do that initially as part
one part two would be the central
registry part three the transportation
of pupils and four mitigation special
education costs
so with that we're going to open up 147
and we're addressing
part one
application for federal student aid do
we have if there are people online
listening if you want to speak to this
particular part will you please put up
your hands show
users
and I I don't is Senator Khan singing
he's the prime sponsor uh is he
available or if Senator Ruth Ward is
C7
Senator Ward if you're out there can you
uh
introduce the bill
um
if you can speak to you know briefly
about the sections or or the section
you're involved would that be
appreciated
it's possible that she didn't hear
um
do we have any reps or Senators for the
okay what I'm going to do I'll do the
same thing with this saying that we know
that Senator Khan the prime sponsors are
still out in Chicago
so I will introduce Senate Bill 147 for
him on his behalf I did talk to him
earlier several days ago and he asked
did I do it if he wasn't here
um I'm going to introduce for the record
my name is Rick Ladd I come from
Haverhill New Hampshire where I'm a
representative
um I'm going to introduce Senate Bill
147 this is an act adopting Omnibus
legislation relative to student aid
central registry Transportation students
and special education cause
um I will not get into a discussion on
any of these particular sessions I'm
simply going to introduce the bill as
I've done and and and close my
introductory comments representative Mr
chair we do have Senator Bradley in I
don't know if he is uh speaking to a
particular he would be doing the Special
Olympics part four but he's welcomed as
a sponsor of some of this legislation to
Bradley
and I'm not sure if he's okay well there
he is good morning good morning Senator
Jay is out in Chicago so could you
introduce Senate Bill 147 for us yes uh
certainly happy to do that
um Senator 147 is one of our Omnibus
bills
um there are four pieces to it
um one the first piece deals with
federal student aid uh the second piece
central registry the third
transportation of pupils and my section
which if I
um representative Ladd could testify to
deals with uh special education costs in
small communities
so why don't you Jeff go ahead and
present your section so you can get on
to work yourself then we'll hop back to
section one yeah that would be lovely
because I'm trying to chair uh Senate
Health and Human Services at the same
time so thank you very much so
um
I introduced uh part four of Senate Bill
147 because of what happened in one of
the very small towns in Carroll County
Parts location which I think uh
representative cordelli is very familiar
with
um in Hearts location there was a
apparently a family that moved into the
community
obviously qualified for special
education services but it was very
expensive and given that
um the town of Parts location has so few
people
um it was a very significant and harmful
impact on the overall tax rate of Hearts
location and from what I've been able to
ascertain
this has happened from time to time in
some of the smaller communities in our
state so I
um am proposing and the Senate agreed
with this to add
language to our
um RSA 186 c18 special
education state aid that
the state could designate an additional
250 000 of aid
in particular
um for the smallest towns in the state
um what I indicated was under a hundred
under a thousand uh or fewer residents
and it would obviously be to mitigate
the impact of special ed costs
um I I clearly worked with commissioner
edelblue
um when this first came to my attention
to see if something could be done in the
hearts location
um situation prior to filing this
legislation he informed me that even
though in the last budget we fully
funded catastrophic Aid
um there was just no allowance in the
statute for something that would be
particular like this so
um after Consulting with a commissioner
I filed um this section of the bill that
was included in the Omnibus and I
commend it to you I think they're
probably a lot of communities that are
very small that have a very large impact
and would be helped by this designation
of fund my understanding is it doesn't
um
it doesn't create a new expectation of
more funding it's just allowing that
designation of
um the additional 250
000 for the smallest communities in the
state so thank you Mr chairman thank you
very much uh Senator all right I see uh
you are you gonna able to take a
question or two
sure all right represent heat oh thank
you and thank you Senator um for taking
my question this has been a serious
problem for many many years and for a
place like hearts location it could just
um explode their whole budget how will
they be able to get their money within
that school year and not wait till
um the following year is that what this
bill does
well this would not my understanding is
representative and thank you for the
question would not be retroactive
um it would have to be and let me look
at the effective date I think hang on
UH 60 days after passage so assuming
that
um we were to pass it this year I think
they would qualify for this in the next
okay thank you senator
thank you uh representative and Senator
Bradley I do have one question we have
some communities that are a thousand
residents or less which uh have a real
uh strong
um tax base
um
some of the ski areas for example I
won't say any names
but we also have communities such as
Monroe that have a strong tax base is
there any way that this uh a amount that
you're putting in here the 250 000 would
be earmarked towards the community which
has the low equalized property valuation
well I didn't specifically try to design
language to that effect however if you
look at the way it's written it says the
state may designate an additional 250
000 of funds
for any community
um to mitigate the impacts of special
education costs when emergency
assistance is necessary to prevent
significant financial harm to such
community so I think you could make the
argument that
in a community that has a much more
significant and robust property tax base
that it would not meet that standard
potentially of significant financial
harm I think that's a better way of
doing it than
um
you know set up an arbitrary number
given that you know already the Thousand
or fewer residents is somewhat of an
arbitrary number
thank you I think your phrase theology
does it yes thank you uh representative
Tanner you have one last question and
we're then going to let Senator Bradley
get back to work
uh thank you chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question I was
just wondering how this affects small
towns that are part of a Cooperative
school district and have a a special ed
student
um
you know I'm I'm not certain of the
answer to that I think maybe some of the
experts on uh your committee might have
a better idea of how that would work I
think it
um I believe in the case of Hart's
location they are part of the
I can't remember the SAU number both in
the SAU with Conway and some of the
other Northern Carroll County towns and
it's meant to help that community of
Hearts location so I believe that it
thank you very much Senator Bradley and
uh have a good day
thank you very much and thanks for uh
uh considering this bill and for your
thought on all of the Omnibus bills
thank you thank you
with that where folks we're going to go
back to part one
and take any testimony regarding the
three people that want to testify
Joe Atchison
um
good morning everyone can you hear me
yes we can good morning good morning hi
my name is Joe Atchison I'm vice
president of community engagement and
lending programs at the Neath Network
speaking as a member of the public of
the public on behalf of Nick today
and I wanted to thank the committee for
having me on
um we did want to you know just say a
few things about
um this bill my organization is you know
remaining neutral on the bill but we did
want to highlight some of the great work
that we do in the community and would
like to kind of represent how if the
bill were to pass how we would be able
to support you know the rollout of this
you know across the state uh if you're
not familiar with neef you know we are a
Concord non-profit that has been you
know doing a number of roles in the
community for decades you know all
related to higher education planning and
financing
we do have a center for College Planning
you know as part of our organization
that has been around since 1995 and you
know does a number of Outreach and
activities you know all free to the
public you know across the state of New
Hampshire we work closely with you know
all schools particularly public schools
in the state as well as other
community-based organizations to deliver
College Planning workshops
uh and information related to you know
navigating the entire college experience
from application to financing and
everything in between
uh the center for College Planning team
also delivers free personalized advising
sessions uh in pre-covet of course we're
doing these in person we are currently
have adapted that model to you know
support you know students and families
with a virtual model for that for those
advising sessions
um as far as the FAFSA Trends you know
what we have seen nationally is that as
of early April you know FAFSA completion
is down uh about 6.7 percent
uh with New Hampshire FAFSA rates uh
down 7.6 percent here to date as of
early April
um in underserved communities and with
low-income school districts and we're
seeing we need to even start or drop off
you know with decreases of around 11
percent
uh as of April you know we are in New
Hampshire at a 48 completion rate for
FAFSA uh for this Academic Year
uh moving forward you know if this if
this bill were to pass you know neef has
the infrastructure in place to expand
our services and you know support
schools in the rollout of this
legislation uh we would we would work
with our students and families to reduce
the strain and assist with making you
know what is what can be a very
overwhelming process less daunting to
them as individuals
we do support you know the removal of
all barriers you know for New Hampshire
students in their pursuit of their
higher educational goals and and
aspirations career aspirations as well
and you know we do feel that we could
you know greatly assist schools in this
rollout
um we are on we are in agreement with uh
you know the amendment to align this
with the
2020-23-24 school year which aligned
with the FAFSA of simplification
legislation at the national level
uh this would allow Neve to you know
increase Staffing levels as needed you
know in support of you know providing
greater support and resources to the
school Community
uh such as in additional training and
professional development for school
counselors that we work closely with
across the state uh we would also you
know could also develop a informational
and educational campaign to help the
general public in understanding you know
in terms of you know you know and again
you know I do want to highlight you know
while we are remaining neutral we remain
you know committed to you know
um
any changes that welcome you know FAFSA
completion uh increased Equity you know
among student populations and you know
certainly we do not want to see you know
students and families leaving
um money on the table at the federal
level that could be available to them to
to assist in their higher education
pursue
thank you very much for your testimony
uh are there any questions
for Mr Atchison
yeah represent Heat well thank you again
Mr chair and and thank you Joe for
taking my question one of the
populations I've always been concerned
about
um with regard to
um Aid uh the foster children in our
state
um is there a way to uh especially reach
out to them to let them know that
something like this is available at this
point in time because I think it would
be a huge asset for them and and thank
you for taking my question
it's a great question yeah and I think
you know that example I think is just
one you know example of the you know
some of the vulnerable populations that
we seek to assist you know throughout
our spectrum of services so
um our advisors do work you know with
you know foster children and parents and
families today certainly again with this
you know proposed legislation we could
incorporate that into part of our
campaign I think it as an organization
that is you know part of the concerns
that we have in terms of you know
students who are vulnerable who may have
a technology Gap at home who may have
parents that are you know for for any
variety of reasons you know perhaps not
fully participating in the uh in in the
FAFSA process or are not available to so
we would need to you know reach out to
you know those vulnerable
students and families you know I think
of like in students with incarcerated
parents as well and you know kind of let
them know and you know the bill does
include a waiver you know for for people
to decline to pursue to fill out the
application uh we certainly hope that
most people would fill out the
application and not utilize the waiver
but to your point you know it would
certainly require an educational
thank you thank you very much further
questions uh Mr Atchison
is
h
welcome Mr Carson's
thank you chairman Ladd uh thank you
members of the committee I appreciate
your time and energy and
um I'll try to keep my comments brief uh
as for the record my name is Joel
Carstens I'm both the director of
financial aid at the University of New
Hampshire and I'm also the current
president of the New Hampshire
Association of student financial aid
administrators and Association of
financial aid professionals throughout
the state whose sole focus at colleges
and universities is to help students
afford the their college education today
I'm speaking on behalf of the University
system of New Hampshire
as you know over the next decade our
state is facing declining numbers of
high school graduates and that smaller
populations of high school graduates
will likely have a different
socioeconomic profile than historically
have been suggested by post-secondary
enrollment in the past
the next decade is also a time as the
committee is well aware when the need
for New Hampshire workers with
post-secondary degrees and credentials
has never been higher and that uh and
that need is increasing rapidly it's not
an option for New Hampshire to leave
these students behind who both need the
post-secondary degrees and credentials
for personal success
and also the New Hampshire economy that
requires a strong environment future
also needs those students to be uh or
those New Hampshire Granite Staters to
be participating so University system of
New Hampshire supports efforts such as
SB 147 to make the pursuit and
attainment of post-secondary degrees and
credentials part of a comprehensive and
coordinated financial literacy strategy
for New Hampshire
the US Department of Education has
announced the free application for
federal student aid will be simplified I
believe you've heard that testimony from
other members today beginning with the
2023-2024 Academic Year anyone who's
completed a FAFSA in the past 20 years
knows that this is very good news that
the simplification process will benefit
everyone
um and as a financially professional I'm
excited about this simplification and
what this may mean for students in being
able to submit a FAFSA in the future but
my 25 years of education Finance
experience tells me that this change
will encounter issues both known and
unforeseen and this is going to be bumpy
on the federal side so in the Senate the
university system and then haspa members
I represent as the association's
president supported an amendment to the
bill that would delay the implementation
until the 2023 school year to align with
this Federal simplification and we
appreciate the Senate adopting this
Common Sense change
and that will allow New Hampshire
Department of Education as well as the
federal effort and public schools time
to prepare and implement the necessary
systems that will track these
requirements at the state and local
level so as you can as you know from
this bill this is going to put some
pressure on both the Department of
Education likely as well as the state
and local level Public School Systems to
track all of these different
applications and whether students have
met this High School graduation
requirement
delaying for a year gives those systems
times to those participants time to
appropriately be able to track and
develop systems that will help do that
in summary completing a FAFSA is a
positive step that each high school
graduate with post-secondary intentions
and those who may be on the fence
particularly due to financial concerns
can take so the university system of New
Hampshire is ready to continue our
support of FAFSA completion and granite
Staters post-secondary education Pursuit
and attainment I'm happy to entertain
any questions that the committee may
have
thank you thank you very much are there
not seeing the answer oh yes
representative luno
thanks very much Mr chair and uh and and
thank you um Mr Carson's for uh for
testifying this morning
um just a quick question
um you know we we we just finished up
with a bill uh Senate Bill uh 44 where
we talked about the the potential use in
the future for uh Pell Grants to to help
um you know pay for Workforce
Development uh you know Pro credentials
for Workforce developments do you have
to fill out the FAFSA to qualify for
pelt yes you would
um so students would be required to
complete a FAFSA in order to determine
their eligibility for the federal Pell
Grant the simplified
um FAFSA form um is going to boil things
down to about 18 questions
um right now there are about a hundred
so
um the simplification process we think
dovetails very nicely with this
requirement
um and we we strongly encourage the
house to to also adopt that delayed
implementation until the 2023-24
academic year when that FAFSA
simplification will be available
uh that that's excellent just uh just a
quick um uh comment I believe that delay
is actually in the bill that we're um it
doesn't require further Amendment for
that yeah thank you that's excellent
thank you
thank you very much Mr Carson are there
further questions
not seeing hands thank you very much
Joel
um the the next person I'd like to call
I I think we have some technical support
from the Department of Education
available to us
uh it is uh Diana Fenton there or
thank you
good morning I'm actually going to defer
to Steve Appleby on this but I look
forward to speaking to the committee on
okay
I just have a question for uh Mr Appleby
Steve
um I'd like to ask the question that
currently we have in all these high
schools counselors with the
responsibility of meeting with students
to prepare them for the next step
following graduation from high school uh
be it uh uh technical school be a
post-secondary be it the military Etc
um the the language in this bill
seems to me that it's it's a
prerequisite to receiving a high school
diploma what the possible option that if
a child decides not to do this uh they
may not have to
um I asked the question why is this
necessary if we have counselors in the
schools why aren't they doing this is
just part of the job that's supposed to
necessary
uh Steve Appley division director for
the Department of Education uh thank you
for the question
um
I don't have a good answer to your
question to be frank
the uh
you know currently there are a lot of
programs Statewide where schools and
those counselors work with students and
the
folks put on a
an annual event to try and encourage
beyond that I I'm not sure how to answer
foreign
legislation provides for a waiver
um if the family does not want to fill
out a bot a bicep form
um and that the waiver would be created
by the Department of Education
um
which the department also be responsible
for a tracking waivers versus
those who
filled out a fisa application
um
to be responsible for tracking those
Ary good morning thank you for the
question representative if I understood
you correctly you broke up a little bit
at the end you're asking if we would be
also tracking those waivers did I
understand that correctly
yes
yeah
um I I would assume where
the department is granted rulemaking
Authority on this matter that we would
thank you very much are there further
questions for the Department
not saying thank you very much Steve
uh who else do we have somebody else to
testify in part one it's got her hand
raised Deborah speier and
she's not signed up to testify but her
hand has been up for a while so for part
lowered our hands so she
moved on the list okay so what we're
going to do now we're going to move into
part two of this bill
part two of the bill
I got her back she just moved all over
on part one okay is that is that better
yes yes good morning everyone uh thank
you chairman Ladd for the opportunity to
speak on this bill
um relative to the student aid first
section I'm Debbie scary and I serve as
the president of the New Hampshire
college and university Council located
in in Concord
um some of you may be familiar with nhcc
we're a non-profit Consortium of the
public and private institutions of
higher education in the state and these
institutions are recognized and highly
regarded for their teaching research and
community service activities
and I'm really here very quickly to say
that college access and success is a
strategic priority of the nhcuc and we
strongly support increasing the number
of students attending college we really
feel strongly that attending or
attaining a college degree rather is an
important accomplishment for students it
increases their earning potential as
you've heard from several other folks
who have testified today and at the same
time while it serves uh individuals we
also know that it serves our state in
terms of our Workforce Development
HB 147 I'm sorry that's SB 147 seeks to
require students to complete the FAFSA
um prior to high school graduation and I
think in order to encourage more
students to apply and attend college
it's important to remove all the
barriers which the FAFSA has been
previously and this would be an
excellent step moving forward to serve
to students and families of New
Hampshire thank you very much for the
opportunity to speak
thank you very much uh Deborah are there
not seeing the hands up thank you very
okay with that we will move into part
two
just uh regards a central registry in
the Department of Education to maintain
records
since she was scheduled to testify on
this proportion of the bill I don't know
if
she's there now but
please
do we have any other testimony on this
section
okay are there any members attendees
that have questions on part two of 147.
if you have a question or if you'd like
to offer testimony would you please
S I see nobody
with that we're going to move in to part
three of the bill
relative to Transportation pupils and
contract care in a contract carrier
okay
um do we have anybody from the
the director said
good morning
um good morning representative how are
you can you hear me
yes yeah we can hear you just fine
yes um thank you and um I do want to
start out by introducing myself
Elizabeth bilecki I'm the director of
the New Hampshire DMV
um I want to tell you that we're taking
a neutral position on this but we did
work with Senator Khan on on this
request from him as well and I'm hopeful
that he gave you the background of what
he was trying to do and I'm hopeful that
there are other speakers behind me that
that can really articulate the need and
why they were working on this
um we do oversee Pupil Transportation in
the state and I do have Sergeant Kelby
with me who can answer any questions
that you have about the transportation
of students and our oversight and
enforcement of that as well
centercon identified a need for
additional transportation for longer
distances and he worked with us to
ensure that the two are pretty much
tracking the same as far as the
qualifications of the driver would be
very similar to the qualifications that
school bus drivers have to meet right
now as far as background certification
and training requirements as well he
also delineated the difference between
utilizing a school bus for school
transportation to and from school and
this proposal include includes only
transportation for school related
activities that would require travel of
at least 75 miles
um so with that I will stop right here
and see if you have any questions that I
oh yes representative woodcock
thank you Mr chairman thank you director
for saying my question do you know I I
couldn't pick it up from reading the
legislation do you know if that's 75
miles is total or one way
um I I can only see what I'm reading as
well it says travel of at least 75 miles
I know in discussing with the senator
Khan
um he looked at it both ways whether it
would be a round trip travel or one way
but I don't think that bill clarifies
what his intent is with this thank you
director and thank you Mr chairman
this weekend representative Woodcock I
did have a call with Jay regarding that
same question and uh it wasn't really
defined clearly to me I I'm
understanding at 75 miles each way okay
so for you you know it wouldn't be just
30 plus something miles either way so
okay
are there further questions for uh
director balaki
I I do have one uh director can you
please explain to me if there's a
different requirement for drivers that
are driving that are a contract carrier
that are carrying uh you know more than
16 children do they have different
requirements or do are they the same as
they are for
um what we're using for our school buses
going to and fro uh to school
um thank you for the question
representative and there there are
differences and um I know that Sergeant
Kelby is also listening in perhaps he
could raise his hand and and he could
really uh in in a lot of detail explain
that to you as well but there are
differences in um licensing requirements
background requirements and so forth so
I am not sure I was able to identify
himself
yes we'd like to hear a little bit more
about the background checks and what has
to be done for the driver and the
contract carrier
[Music]
sure I again I'm not sure if Sergeant
he'll be raised us again I I see him on
hello
yes we can hear you sir I'm having some
I'm having some internet connectivity
problems
um
I apologize uh you wanted to know the
background on uh uh motor care motor
coach drivers as opposed to school bus
drivers sir that's right the background
check yes what are there different
requirements are they are they similar
for the two for your regular school bus
driver going to and from school taking
the kids to and from school first a
contract carrier that may be doing one
of these field trips uh 75 miles each
each ways and are they the same
background checks for the driver that's
driving the bus
under current legislation the uh
any anyone transporting children to and
from school related activities under
current state law 259.96
uh states that all drivers uh need to
undergo a criminal background check
motor vehicle background check uh
minimum training
um and the names have to be submitted to
a roster
um to the state of New Hampshire the
department of safety that's outside of
the requirements for Department of
Education so
to answer your question uh yes currently
well actually no currently if you're
driving a school bus be it a charter uh
school bus or a home to school fashion
School Bus you're a school bus driver
um that means you you have to have a
minimum amount of training undergo all
the criminal motor vehicle background
checks
um for motor carriers uh like Concord
Coach
under current law they are not allowed
to transport for a variety of reasons
and they are not uh currently required
to undergo a motor vehicle criminal
background checks or have minimum
training so uh it's important to note
that the legislation which I still have
not seen
um I I don't have a copy of that
legislation unfortunately so I can't
weigh in one way or the other
um under on the proposed legislation as
it has been verbally explained to me
uh uh the motor coach like a Concord
Coach driver uh would undergo a
certification to be a school bus driver
but again I can't I haven't seen that I
don't have a copy of that legislation
um so so uh I really can't answer
anything relative to the proposed
legislation
again um I can add that the proposed
legislation would actually
bring into the scope for contract
carriers or motor coach drivers would
bring them into the scope of what's
currently required of the school bus
drivers so the third section of the bill
where it says that they would be subject
to their requirements for training and
criminal background checks required
under RSA 189 13A those are the
background checks required by the
Department of Education and then it
continues on to say as well as school
bus driver certificate requirements
under RSA 260 329 that would bring them
into the scope of the requirements that
current school bus drivers are required
to compete
thank you for very much for that
clarification director and Sergeant uh
represent Leon do you have a question of
either the sergeant or the director
uh yes thank you Mr chair I do have a
question of the director uh would this
extend this these School Bus
requirements to all drivers for a
business like Concord Trailways if they
do some school business or would that
only be for those those drivers who are
approved for school trips
um thank you for the question
representative the way that the bill is
um currently structured would be any
drivers that would be driving kids for
school related activities would have to
meet those requirements
if you if a motor coach company has
drivers that would not be participating
in those type of related activities they
would not be required to meet those
minimum standards
thank you
um my question was very similar to
representative Leons thank you okay so
you're good
are there further questions of the DMV
I don't see any thank you very much for
both of you for you know helping us out
here
thank you for your questions thank you
thank you
I would like to justify on this bill
okay we have Diana Fenton from the
Department of Education who would like
good morning good morning Diana
I apologize I'm testifying from the
woods of Mount Vernon and I keep losing
my connection
um so with the committee's permission
I'd like to testify as to part two I
think I missed my opportunity and I
appreciate
being able to Circle back a little bit
um part two would simply give the
Department of Education access
to the records maintained by
DHHS their central registry
um
when we are credentialing first-time
applicants
members of the committee might be
familiar with the bill that was passed
last session
which allows the department to do a
criminal background check on first-time
applicants for teaching credentials
this bill Senate Bill 147 part 2 would
expand the Department's ability to have
access to the dcyf registry
it occurred to the Department of
Education and our partners at dcyf that
if dcyf has flagged an individual who
they believe should not have access to
Children uh doe is of the position that
that individual should not be able to
gain access to Children via the
Department of Education
and we look forward to working with our
sister agencies so that we are all on
the same page I will share with you that
we had this situation occur
um on an individual from the state of
Massachusetts who is on the
Massachusetts list of DCF they have a
different version but their version of
dcyf uh that person was on a list in
Massachusetts of not being able to have
access to children and they came up to
New Hampshire and became credentialed to
teach in New Hampshire
so Amy was made aware of the situation
and we have worked closely with our
partners at dcyf to craft this
legislation
doe has an individual a position that
can take this role on so it will not be
of any additional cost we do not believe
and as dcyf changes their system of
their central registry and makes it
electronic I think that access will will
be even easier to address
I appreciate your time and I'm happy to
take any questions
so uh Diana thank you very much so
this part two has been put together by
the department is that correct
it has been put together uh by the
department in conjunction with our
partners at dcyf I worked with attorney
Rebecca Ross this was a joint uh Venture
and so we we crafted this language
together yes that is correct okay going
on part three because that's where we
were when we backed up a little bit
there understood thank you yeah you're
more than welcome um goes to the
department have any issues with part
three
uh no we do not we had some questions
that have been addressed uh concerning
the clarity of the language about the 75
miles
but in terms of the background checks of
school bus drivers
um that is a function that the
department is currently working on
getting up to speed on based on pending
legislation we're working on our work
with our partners at the department of
safety to get that
um
fully effective
um so note that the department doesn't
have a position on part three of this
legislation thank you thanks very much
are there any questions yes
representative thank you uh Mr chair uh
attorney just going back to your
response on the 75 miles you said you
had an explanation of that we don't have
that at least I don't have that from the
last couple questions we've asked can
you tell us is the interpretation of 75
miles one way or round trip
uh thank you for the question we didn't
have any additional information I was
just looking listening to the previous
testimony okay I will just look back at
my notes
um and I believe it was understood to be
75 miles each way rather than a total
okay thank you so much thank you I think
that's what the intent of Senator Khan
was when I talked to one of them and he
was out in Chicago uh he was referring
to 75 miles in a Direction so that has
the reason I was asking that was more on
that one little line in that paragraph
that talks about special education
activities I mean the the bulk of the
the area is special events after school
like those types of things but there is
one of those small three or four word
disclaimer about special education so I
just I think it was is this going to run
into a new way to transport youngsters
who are special ed youngsters
um during the day for activities or
events or or therapies that was the 75
piece so that was the intent of my
questioning thank you yeah and that
might be something for attorney Fenton
to look at too when you're starting a
talk special ed you're starting to get
in a different domain altogether thank
you yes uh are there any further uh
folks I want to test it thank you very
much uh uh attorney Fenton yes
we have Tim Brewer
Brewer
r-u-e-h-r number two
um
hello all right yes we can hear you and
are you prepared to speak on part three
I am um
I am the CFO at uh Keene School District
SAU 29 we have uh
seven districts here some are small Keen
being the largest and I've been here for
20 years in uh doing this work
I wanted to give a little background
although many of you may have know this
I was surprised to learn uh
that though it's a common practice
throughout the state especially in our
Athletics for long-haul trips using a
coach motor coach bus is illegal to
transport students currently in the
state of New Hampshire although if
you've been to your
your kids games or your grandkids games
you'll see these coach buses rolling up
everywhere in fact your student may have
gone to DC or Quebec or the Museum of
Science on one of these buses
um as mine had uh and the department of
safety uh director by lucky and uh the
sergeant have been incredible uh
resources so when I found this out a
couple years ago I of course uh
shivered a little bit knowing that if
one of these buses had an accident
that not only could I be liable but my
towns and districts would be extremely
liable how would they defend themselves
putting students on a mode of
transportation that is currently illegal
that's what's happening right now I've
called private companies it's still
going on today
they aren't rostered they aren't
background checked and they're driving
our students on buses that aren't
approved by the state of New Hampshire
so I went to Senator Khan who's worked
tirelessly to try to address this
situation
um so the first reason was the liability
the second Department of Safety will
tell you and and I I agree a hundred
percent that the safest vehicle on the
road is a yellow school bus
but there becomes a
a sense of practical you have to be
practical uh a yellow school bus driving
kindergartners and first graders on a
two-hour trip should have a bathroom for
example a football team needs storage if
you've seen in a hockey the amount of
gear they had our football team would
have to travel in three school buses for
one team that doesn't include uh JV to
go to a away game in Keene we're often
two hours away
I agree that the intent is
One Way 75 miles in fact I recently
negotiated a new contract where my
provider my school bus provider pays us
back 500 every time we use a coach bus
uh that's over 90 miles
um we wanted coach bus simply for Long
Haul we're not trying to take business
away from school bus companies we want
it to be safe but you have to be
practical you're going to Washington DC
you're not taking a yellow school bus
you're driving to Berlin I talked to a
business administrator today who told me
I said why are you still doing this
you're at Great risk he goes I'm not
putting my students on a yellow school
bus for two and a half hour trip it's
not happening so we're just risking it
so this is an important issue
um and and I I really thank you for
listening and considering uh solving
this issue because to most people it's a
small issue but to me when my
reputation's on the line and my
District's liabilities on the line and
student safety we need to address this
sooner than later it's a real issue I
appreciate it
thank you very much for the information
that's uh good stuff uh are there
questions
I don't see any hands up thank you very
much
so at this point in time we're going to
go into part four the last section in
this particular bill which we've already
had uh
Senator Bradley and former as to what
it's all about
um we will have uh are there any books
he's with the Londonderry School
District
am I good yes we can hear you yes Peter
I'll be brief okay
um everything Tim said um is true
um
I'll tell you Londonderry for example we
have the Atlanta marching band
um any long trip is used on a coach
coach bus now
um the number one issue what he brought
up was
um I believe many of the school
districts have a week or half a week
trip to DC
um and we will line up somewhere around
11 coach buses to take the kids from
obviously Londonderry into DC
we've also use coach buses on um for any
lawn field trips field trips or
Athletics
um we've got to remember
no way does this are we talking about
using coach buses or the regular
transportation of students from home to
school school to home
there you are required to have the
yellows and remember the yellows are
there to control the traffic of the road
when you're doing Athletics or
activities you don't really need the
yellows there's no traffic there's no
road traffic
to control the bus pulls up to the to
the building
students load and of course every every
school district has a policy on how many
chaperones or coaches are going to be
you know are required if it's a field
trip or that we're a team
so they're adults always on the bus
there's no Road to Cross no traffic to
control
they get on the bus they go to the
destination they get off the bus with
the chaperones and coaches
do their thing and and come back
um
there's there's there's a often
um va's pulling the hair out all the
time
trying to juggle how to get kids to and
from home and school in the afternoon
in dealing with all the field trip
requirements and all the athletic events
that go on
um
so allowing legally uh because it it
does go on uh now
um
this flexibility or another tool for
districts to use especially on long
trips
uh really helps us out immensely and
before I leave there's two things and
then I'll I'll be done I know you get a
lot of work Eddie up
someone along the line and not not this
year but the chairman can make a note or
someone make a note
we've got to address the issue of a
Statewide
roster of school bus drivers
I'll give you a perfect example
for the most part I always say the most
part I never say I would there are two
big school school bus companies in the
state STA and First Student
Londonderry has sta Derry has first
student
so I'll just use an example we're at a
bus drivers we're out flush we've got
the Middle School softball team has to
go somewhere wherever wherever they need
to go to
why couldn't I
use a first student
driver from Derry who's rosted certified
licensed everything with the state
right now I can't
because Mrs Jones is not rosted with the
school district of Londonderry
even though she has all the
certifications and licenses whatever
so it's someone on the line
somebody could have could look at
addressing that if you're arrested if
you're licensed if you're certified to
be a school bus driver
and another District needs for whatever
reason why couldn't Londonderry in this
case
hi and Mrs Jones
um for a student
to take the middle school team to
whatever they're going
um I'd like you know someone could take
a note maybe we can
come back to that next year and be and
maybe address that before I leave Mr
chairman on part four you asked a
question about
um you know when we're talking small
school districts but some of them have a
healthy tax base
if you look and just think just just a
suggestion
if you look at the department of Ed
webpage
there was a table that talks about the
average assessment for a student
and then there's a state average and
then it has the average assessment per
student by each district
so you may want to use that as a
guideline something on the lines if
you're lower than the state average
and your thousand students or less that
may help you qualify to your point
about you know looking at the tax base
of the of the of the um school district
and and not just the population that
that's kind of the Crux for those of us
who've been around here too long that
was kind of the basis of the Claremont 2
decision
where you know how hot does a tax base
work to supply the cost of Education
just a suggestion for you I I took a
note when when you were talking about
that pot with uh Senator Bradley
thank you very much thank you very much
Peter I appreciate your information here
um are there questions for
senator in a representative
representative yes thank you Mr chair Mr
Carol thank you for taking my question
um in your testimony you indicated that
most school districts particularly one
of the USIS we have a requirement for a
large number of corporate carriers like
to to Washington or or trips to marching
band with equipment or football
um that they have their own protocols
and they understand that in your
protocols in Londonderry do you have a
requirements for background checks of
those drivers
no
okay you're using you know what that's a
good point and I may have to um uh I'm
going to look into that I appreciate
that thank you thank you Mr chair thank
you are there further questions for Mr
Carol
not seeing hands up thank you very much
yes yes we have a panel uh member of the
um
yes
good morning good morning
um sorry I'm I'm down here in the corner
in West Milan New Hampshire so I have a
little bit of internet problem so if I
leave you I apologize
um I have been a manager of Laidlaw and
then first student and over the years
I've been in the business 30 years I now
own a little school bus company d l
Transit and as Laidlaw and first student
we have had to use our area coach
companies
um on these long trips especially due to
the age-old driver shortage
um
in the early days I did not know the
whole piece of
um that we really weren't supposed to be
um the schools requested it we would
book it until in later days we had to
stop that
um but the purpose these coaches serve
as Tim stated as Mr curio stated with
um being able to put all their
possessions underneath safe so they're
not projectiles on our big school buses
trying to secure these items is very
hard
um also when you don't have enough
drivers being able to get the coach
buses to be able to take
um a large group so as Tim stated we
don't have to utilize three of our
drivers to do one trip is huge
um
I know in our area we utilize Thomas and
Wilson Bus and both of them their
drivers do go through criminal
background checks however they are not
as yearly and as extensive as you know
our school bus drivers I would worry in
this area at least that that our
area coach providers would they be able
to find drivers that would be willing to
go through all the ins and outs to get
their school bus certificate that that
could be a problem you know trying to
trying to find that for you know this
these schools
quite often the schools when their teams
make it to playoffs it's kind of an
added little Boon to put them on a a
coach instead of a school bus
um and you know that these are all
reasons I would be for this bill that I
think
um the coach buses have a purpose as
well as our big yellows don't get me
wrong as Tim stated I don't think
there's anything safer than a big yellow
um but I also think that the coach buses
in their drivers sometimes I had drivers
that went and drove coach buses so
they're
um
all about safety thank you thank you
very much are there questions for uh
Miss Leslie
not seeing hands up thank you very much
for your testimony today thank you
you're welcome
so with that we're
done 147.
do you have any numbers for us on how
many Mr Mr chair yes
um I had a question earlier on part four
with a special education about what
happens in Cooperative schools and I was
kind of waiting until somebody from the
Department or
um somebody else uh because uh Senator
Bradley said to wait
to answer that question do you know if
that's
in a Cooperative school where you have
because we're not basing this on the
number of students we're basing it on
the number of residents of the community
um
if you had a Cooperative District some
of them have these very small towns
drawn in
and how that's going to work out I I
think that when we have represent Tanner
is a good question that you've asked
that we should we're not going to be
exacting anything today that we have the
opportunity to call over to the special
ed department and to the Folks At Doe
and get a response to that for you okay
am I been out I've been unmuted um we're
looking at possibly Mark what's Mark's
last name
Magnolia yeah but he's in finance so I
okay so let's see if uh he has any kind
of help for you here on that question
representative Tanner can you see it
awesome
hi representative Vlad
um how are you doing so so um adequacy
um Mark manganello with the Department
of Education
um with adequacy it's based on it's
driven by the municipality but the way
um special education goes out it goes
out to the school district so it would
there's your answer representative so
there there as a follow-up Mr chair yes
go ahead so there would be no
um relief for a small town that happened
to be part of a Cooperative District
or with the Cooperative District
uh see some relief because that small
um yes
um
so the this the community is part of the
Cooperative so the Cooperative shares
that burden
um they educate that student and so they
would see the relief but yeah that's
that's um it's not targeted for that
particular municipality but it is
targeted towards the school district
and help you out representative Tanner
I I think it's still unclear to me but
uh hopefully we'll get it's still on
inclusively also and I think we need to
get a little bit more definition from
I did I mean I basically it was the same
issue I mean I have near me and in my
district a very small town of Roxbury
um and but Roxbury is part of a much
larger Cooperative District wood Roxbury
as a very small town be eligible for
this additional Aid
that's a question we need answered yeah
yeah and I think that's what represent
Tanner was also it is yeah so we will
and and Mark if you hear that from us
right now you might pass that on and try
and get some resolution for us over at
okay with that we're going to close uh
uh Senate Bill 147 uh what what are our
numbers there
all right well rep Shaw's gonna have to
double check my numbers I have 12 and
support
zero opposed to neutral
yes I haven't divided we have five cards
okay okay thank you very much
so we have uh 148 in front of us and
we're supposed to start uh about an hour
ago but uh I think it's important we get
all the testimony and answers these
questions done properly before we move
on to the next bill
so here we are with 148 I'm going to
start this out and um this bill does
have more folks that are interested in
it than we've had previously
um so we're going to start it out uh but
we may have to take a break somewhere
along the way here for a launch
um yes uh we have several Senators that
um our participants in various parts
within here we have Senator Prentice for
one and we have Senator Ward I don't
know if Senator Waters he signed up as
well
are any of those able to introduce this
bill
ERS Senator Waters
I just promoted him and I'm trying again
go ahead Senator Waters
um thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee and I didn't
know if Senator Ward was here to
introduce part one and I don't know how
you wanted to proceed on on the various
parts but the way we're doing this Dave
is that we are introducing the bill as a
total then we're wading through that by
Parts part one part two part three part
four for example Jeb talk to part four
of the previous Bill
well thank you and um if Senator Ward
isn't here I'd be happy to do this
um
so um Senate Bill 148 comes uh to you
with uh five parts that passed through
Senate education five to zero and uh
through the Senate 23 to one we
endeavored as with all these dreaded
Omnibus bills and again I apologize for
doing this to you all
um but the vetting operation in the
Senate was to try to make sure that
anything that was controversial or would
not be bipartisan was eliminated from
the original Bill and so that's what we
bring
um before you and uh if Senator Ward is
not here I can introduce part one and
then if you would let me introduce um
Parts uh my two parts uh part two and
part five uh one after the other that
would help with my schedule but that's
up to you um
Senator what we did
was Senator Bradley introduced the bill
he was the only Senator hanging around
at the time and we let him speak to his
car immediately if you'd like to speak
to your parts immediately so then you
can get on with other Senate business
that would be fine
well thank you Mr chairman members of
the
of the committee um so I'll start with
I'm Senator Waters District Four
okay part two all right thank you thank
you Mr chairman rolling right along
um so this bill uh deals with Career and
Technical education it was developed by
the Department of Education uh
particularly Eric frauerth who is the
CTE Statewide director and I believe he
is available for uh questions that may
go to him it was also developed by the
CTE advisory Council which was
established a few years ago with
representative Ladd who was a co-sponsor
of this section I do know that Senator
aladd has some ideas for some changes to
this section on on some language about
the ctes and I've I've talked about
those with him and I and I support them
as far as this section goes some of it's
some housekeeping language there is some
policy to catch up with changes in the
CTE system and dual concur enrollment
and then also some changes to to catch
up with the new
Perkins Law which was implemented over
the last couple of years so I'll try to
go through
um rather quickly Mr chairman giving
your
your time
um
first off we had some definitional
change there uh on lines 27 to make sure
that private school or home school are
also included uh by definition in the
sending District
um then the next uh part has and you'll
see this in several places in the bill
that we wanted to clarify
um that construction and renovation also
included expansion replacement when it
comes to the cycle of funding for the
CTE facilities we've been on a 30-year
cycle of construction and renovation of
these schools and in four years we'll be
turning the crank again to start that
cycle over so it's felt that we needed
to be sure I mean some of these schools
are so old they might have to be
replaced some they're going to be needed
expanded some just a little bit of
renovation is going to be uh needed for
them so that's why
um that is there
then the transportation issue on page
um three transportation and tuition has
been an area of concern for the ctes I
know representative Ladd is much
concerned about this as as well because
we're afraid that over the last several
years some sending districts have begun
to put a cap on a number of students who
can get a career in technical education
because the amounts of the
transportation tuition provided through
d-e-e doe uh didn't did not meet the the
need
now I just want to note there is no
physical note on this section because as
always this is governed by what ends up
in house bill one and two
but it's aspirational here to say that
it's important to budget the full cost
of transportation and of course that
will be determined by the budget writers
and as we do now whatever that amount is
it gets apportioned out but this
recognizes that issue that we're facing
and then there's just a little
clarification about when the
reimbursement funds are distributed uh
to the schools
you'll see again some language on the
construction and re replacement
issue that consider continues over the
next um page and again just just
clarifying some things about about that
and some needed language changes there
then on the next page and I'm now on
page four
I mentioned earlier The Advisory Council
on Career and Technical education
if you're not familiar this just been a
really terrific Council uh it has CTE
directors some legislators uh doe
community college system and then most
importantly business Representatives
people from the various businesses and
sectors that are served by ctes are
there to you know advise as to what is
needed for Workforce Development
we felt uh that there needed to be a
high school counselor officially on
um the council and uh so that is what
has been added added here
um and then we needed to stagger the
terms of the members that are on that
Council as as well
um then the next part here gets into the
issue of the um
the rule making for the career Readiness
credential some of you may recall we
passed a career readiness
credential which could be fulfilled in a
great variety of ways including CTE
course taking
um and doe came back to us and said they
needed some rule making Authority and
this got caught up in the covert last
year so that's why we
um put it uh in in here
um the next thing on page five is just
that technical language change that uh
the the new Perkins Act is called
strengthening Career and Technical
education the 21st century Act of 2018.
so that's why that is uh that is here
um then the next uh part on page five
um some housekeeping to change the
naming of uh some folks who serve in the
pre-engineering and Technology
curriculum and pre-engineering and
Technology advisory Council system
language uh clean up there
and then um some more
issues about you know catching up with
legislative language and some policy
changes that have been made this deals
with the Dual and concurrent
enrollment program
and I do want to say thank you thank you
thank you house for restoring and
increasing the funding for this program
it is it is a smashing success and if
we're talking about career Pathways and
Workforce Development and keeping our
students in the state and getting good
jobs this this has just proved to be a
great tool to do that so students can in
dual concurrent enrollment programs can
take classes that earn them Community
College
credit and just save them so much money
and give them a leg up on their their
work so um an important thing here is
that we heard from the ctes that you
know the the stem having stem courses
eligible for this is is great but there
are other areas that really in Career
and Technical education that aren't
technically stem courses but certainly
um are valuable as doing concurrent uh
enrollment classes and would serve the
function of Workforce Development and
just uh just the same same way so that's
why uh that is there and and once again
there's no physical note because the
amount of funding that has been provided
or will be provided we hope in the
budget will determine how that gets
parceled out uh among
um various uh needs for for those funds
so
um that's that's just opens it up a
little bit
um then the next part on a doing
concurrent enrollment program as you may
recall we added grade 10 uh to CTE
eligibility eligibility so that is just
added in there online
um 25 4
um
and uh then
the um
next uh part here bottom of page five
um
asked the uh community college system
um and doe to work together for the
model dual and concurrent enrollment
agreement
that should be used by
ccsnh in a school district to govern uh
that and provide a framework for what is
there
um
and then some more language to catch up
with this um
uh the uh career uh Readiness credential
um it just it would be an awfully good
idea for High School uh freshmen to have
a conversation about how they're going
to
um fulfill that assess their student
career interests we've been working for
quite some time to try to reach back
into lower grades to get students
interested in an earlier stage in Career
and Technical education and career
Readiness
um and this would be a a good way to to
do that
um
then finally Mr chairman on this section
uh some of you may be familiar with the
program we passed a number of years
ago to establish a tax credit program
for companies that want to donate
equipment or have internships or company
Personnel teach at the CTE is a
supervised students who come out to the
workplace has been very successful Eric
for our worth can tell you a little bit
more about how ctes have grabbed on this
to form sector of business
Partnerships and so since it's working
we want to um extend it out for another
another few years
um so Mr chairman I I did it and I'm
glad to move on to part five if you'd
like me to
thank you very much for uh going through
part four there
um
that's an important section of this
field
um yeah if you want to let's see part
five
that's uh environmental and outdoor
outdoor yeah
um
perhaps what you ought to do uh Dave is
just briefly go through it like you did
with me on the horn the other day
I will do that and uh thank you very
much Mr chairman and the committee too I
really appreciate the opportunity to
bring this um before before you
um so this bill uh addresses the
importance of um outdoor education but
particularly this is a Workforce
Development Bill to deal with the
outdoor recreation as just such an
important part of uh our economy and and
everybody thinks of the North country
but really throughout out the state and
um
so there's a lot of language in the
first part of this bill was just finding
so it doesn't go into State Statute but
it's important to list here why for New
Hampshire particularly
um you know education about about the
environment which can lead to careers in
forestry uh or or Forest ecology water
ecology
um Fisheries Marine Science and so on
and then also for outdoor recreation
these are important parts there
um and for me having been on the fish
and game committee when I was in the
house I wanted to emphasize that fishing
and Hunter education courses are also
um this bill was also very timely
because commissioner Caswell has now
funded uh the office of outdoor
recreation in the Bea
um and Scott Crowder some of you may
know has been appointed to that position
this is something that was caught on by
the granite outdoor Alliance which was
formed a few years ago by um the Bea a
lot of private businesses uh and um
uh Senator Senator Bradley and uh so
they've been you know championing at the
bit for this office to get get funded
and so
some language here supports that wants
it to work with our our schools and uh
potentially to work with the National
Organization that is the the 17 or so
states that have this office have a um a
kind of Cooperative agreement that could
be looked in to as as well
um so to get to the heart of the bill
starting on line 33 uh it asks the
Department of Education
to take the existing
model curriculum developed back in 2006
endorsed by the Board of Education
number of years ago and it updated a
couple of years ago so it's an existing
curriculum and a bunch of teachers and
Educators who are interested in that and
um so what it does is say that the the
Department of Education will work with
that that group
than to give to the schools so that as
they look to develop these these
programs they got some great examples
and some models to to use
um then uh and Mr chairman here
um I want to mention that I sent you an
email and
um
to the Committees with a Word document
last night
representative lad and I talked last
week about the fact that um
the senate had passed this bill which
has some criteria for adequate education
changes and of course you've you've
passed and the Senate has passed out of
the policy committee senator who adds
Bill House Bill 242 which also uh
changes the criteria for an adequate
education
so what I did is I went into this bill
and basically took what is in house bill
242.
and uh deleted what I have in these
criteria
um three
six and and uh uh seven and um grafted
in the language from House Bill 242 so
we got Conformity there
and then uh upon the discussion with
representative Ladd it seemed as if it
would make sense uh to add from
this bill
um where it says knowledge of the
biological physical and Earth sciences
and then say including environmental
science which is naturally where it
would be
uh to enable them to understand and
appreciate the world
and Engineering socioeconomic and
geopolitical language challenges around
them and that that's all Senator
representative Ladd's um language and
then same thing on uh criteria Romans 6
the sound Wellness environmental
practices
um using representative Lads language
sound wellness and environmental
practices including outdoor recreation
to enable them to enhance their own
well-being as well as that of others and
then in Romans 7
um skills for lifelong learning
including interpersonal Environmental
Education skills and technological
skills to enable them to learn work
communicate and participate effectively
in a changing Society I'm no
representative Ladd you may have some
other ideas about how to do that but um
you know that's just the point is I
think we do need to conform these bills
so we don't have a have a conflict
um and then lastly uh let me note that
the you're going to be perhaps hearing a
little later from some folks who are
developing community college and high
school programs and outdoor recreation a
great group and this section here
next uh asks the um
uh CTE director to report to advisory
Council on Career and Technical
education about programs and outdoor
recreation and potential for new
programs at the ctes
now why the adequacy changes and why
this section are important
is that we've been told that we really
need to have somewhere in our statutory
language some credit or credentialing
for these programs if students are going
to be able to use them to get those jobs
or to go into
programs at the Community College
University level so that there needs to
be some recognition here for that and
that's what the bill tries to do so um
Mr chairman I I sure hope that was no
longer than what we you and I had talked
about before and it uh it gets out what
you need out there on this part
well thank you very much Senator Waters
um there's a lot in here
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to go on with further testimony uh
there may be some questions for you that
before you escape from us uh would you
be willing to take any questions from
the committee
I would be happy to I have a I have a
meeting at 12 but I can you know toggle
back and forth so I'm I'm happy to
um you know I'll answer some questions
now and then I I can keep one ear
attentive so if some come up later after
others are testified I'll be I'll be
there for you uh representative thank
you well represent Leon you have your
hand up
um thank you Mr chair and thank you
Senator Waters my question is on the
beginning of part two where it includes
children and students in private school
and home school in the sending District
does that create a financial obligation
um they are they already have it it just
clarifies it
um you know that descending District
um is responsible for its students that
go to the receiving district and um a
lot of home school and um
charter school and other students uh do
take CTE programs
and so we just wanted to make sure that
the language is basically this is just
an update of the language to make sure
that they're included in the definition
because this language is from quite a
few years ago before there was much
legislation around either of those so uh
Eric frauerth will be here to fill in
some more detail on that but um it's
just it's just acknowledging uh those
schools and and the importance that CTE
education is for students um you know
whatever form of Education they're
getting in the state they ought to have
an opportunity here
um thank you Senator I'll follow up with
them with the details thank you yeah
thank you representative Tanner you have
a question yeah uh thank you uh chair
and thank you Senator Waters um mine was
kind of around the same issue uh that
homeschooler is when I talked to my
local superintendent and ask him how
many homeschooled students there are in
our district
he says well about uh such and such a
number but he he really doesn't have a
specific number so for a homeschooled
student
that the district is then going to pick
up the tab for do they have to be
registered with the Local District
um in order to do that because how else
would
the district
be able to budget number one number two
how would they
be assured that that student resided uh
had the you know resided in that
District
um it it just seems to me that it's uh
an issue that needs to be clarified more
yeah thank you um representative for
your your question I agree with you I
think um Eric flowers will be able to do
that I do want to note that um you know
I I think it's less likely that a
homeschooled student will be
homeschooled outside of their their
District you know their home is probably
in a district but for the private
schools it's just clarifying it for
private schools actually outside the
district but a student wants to take a
CTE class they ought to be able to do
that but where where do they live
um where it's where they live and uh and
I think also just let's note that this
the tuition and transportation funding
um that is provided from the state is is
so the sending schools get to send their
representative Mullins you have your
hand up yes thank you Mr chair and thank
you senator for taking my question uh
related to what you just said uh are we
to assume in looking at this that
transportation for private school and
homeschooled students to the CTE would
let's ask Eric frauworth about these
because he will he will know how this is
uh this is done a lot of these
individual students
um do find their own way to the ctes uh
or maybe brought by there by our parent
or there's a lot of them can drive
so um but I'm I'm only asking uh as a
follow-up Mr chair and a comment to
Senator Waters I'm only asking as um a
town that represents that Oddity of not
having the school within its boundaries
um our private school students many of
them go to uh I represent Bedford but
many of our private school students go
to Nashua to school and so the question
for me would be you know are we are they
being transported to the CTE in Nashua
are they being transported to the CTE in
Manchester
yeah
well
Eric will ask that but if they're in
Nashville they'd be going to the
National seats the national CTE I mean I
don't know but try to let him let him
address these details
okay it's pretty obvious I'm not sure
just to further complicate this
conversation I did have a discussion
with uh uh Eric frauers over at uh doe
regarding this very topic dealing with
Manchester Exeter and Nashua
and I have put together some amending
language
which would basically say the students
resident District shall be responsible
for providing transportation and paying
the transportation costs and then and
shall then be reimbursed from the state
if a student is permitted to
self-transport the students resident
District shall reimburse the student
according to rules adopted pursuant to
541a until then be reimbursed from State
funds kids that are not driven by the
school district at a rate of 10 cents
per mile May transport if agreed by the
sending District the resident District
be reimbursed 25 cents per mile that is
in rule right now and I think Eric will
be addressing that but we need to
address I think it's time to address
that we have school districts Exeter
Nashua and Manchester
which are shipping kids from one high
school to a CTE Center not located in
that high school they are incurring
Transportation costs that they're not
getting any reimbursement for we need to
address this policy issue
thank you Mr chairman and I think that
you know that is the the the section A
little bit further along in this bill
and it's essential I agree with
everything you're saying and I think
it's an opportunity to provide to the
committee we want to may want to provide
some clarification around the questions
that are being raised about the private
or home school in at the same time so I
think that that can get all done
together
so uh
uh uh um
Senator Waters right now we've jumped
around a little bit and
um we we do have folks ready to talk on
on these sections here but we have not
discussed all the parks leading up to
part three yet we're we haven't talked
about part one and part two
um okay Mr chair yes I did promote Mr
Brown
for all as he raised his hand during
that conversation but we also have
Senator Prentice who has been waiting
um to speak as well so I didn't know
she's part three okay so I didn't know
been talking about uh part two here the
Career and Technical education
and and where we're on that right now we
can come back to part one I think part
one is pretty much uh uh
eliminating the doing it it's language
to make it current with what we're
actually doing
um so
um part two I think we ought to have
Eric come up right now on this and he
may be able to also uh address some of
the issues that uh Senator Waters has
addressed and answered questions of the
committee on part three a two
additionally if I can make it even more
complicated
senator
Ward Hall earlier but she is back now so
it's
what part is she going because it's been
introduced it's been introduced so she
she's welcome to talk on a part that she
wants to talk on okay uh so I will see
if uh Senator Ward wants to speak first
and I'll go back to Mr frauer
that
program
uh I don't want to jump around these
parts okay so I'm sorry if either one of
those senators are speaking to the part
we're on right now with either one or
two okay they're welcome to come in if
not we're gonna okay wipe up this uh
part two okay so Senator Ward
if you're listening I have promoted you
she's part one okay we haven't been able
she's not answering I can't understand
it let's let's enter let's Elevate Eric
and bring him on and and just stay on
this poor technical education here get
this done okay and then then we'll move
good morning
for the for the record I'm Eric Howard
I'm the administrator of the Bureau of
career development at the Department of
Education
and I feel like I'm in an episode of
Doctor Who and my Tardis and I keep
bouncing around I'm not sure where I'm
welcome
thank you very much uh and thank you for
hearing this bill uh uh representative
Ladd and the committee
um I know we've been working on this
actually we had been working on this for
a couple of years and and hit some covid
uh bumps so I'm glad to see it's back
again uh I'm hoping I can answer the
questions that you've already brought up
around private school the home school
and some of the transportation pieces uh
and then I um represented Vlad and I
have spoken about
um some edits that he is going to be
proposing and I do have one additional
um
I guess it's almost an unedit so I think
start first with your questions that you
already had
so with regard to uh the private school
and homeschool question which is a sort
of the first line right in here
in the current legislation in RSA 188
it defines a
sending District
as a school district where a student
resides who attends a regional center
that is not within their home District
so if the law just said that
any homeschool charter school or private
school kid would already be covered
because regardless of where they go to
school
they're sending district is the school
district in which they reside
when Charter Schools sort of started
growing in New Hampshire for some reason
and again this was before me a line was
added into this law specifically about
what happens to Charter School kids and
it was to let people know that if a kid
went to a charter school they're sending
District was not the charter school but
it was wherever the district was that
they lived
and what we've discovered in the past
couple of years is because charter
school students were listed specifically
homeschool and private school students
were almost being taught word in
summonses were being told that they
weren't listed in the legislation and
they couldn't attend CTE and that their
home District wasn't going to do
anything for them so we wanted to
clarify the law by adding this
now a student in New Hampshire can
attend any CTE Center in the state if
there is space
regardless of where it is located so if
say they live in Manchester but they
attend a private school in Nashua
they are welcome to attend the Nashua
te Center if there is a seat available
however their home school district which
is Manchester would be the one that
would be paying the 25 tuition the other
75 percent is still coming from the
state
now again notice I did say if there is
space available
the way the distribution happens is each
each CTE Center has assigned school
districts that belong that belong to it
and there are proportioned seats
based on the percentage of students who
live in each of those towns and
communities so a homeschool is another
great example if a homeschool student
lives in Manchester and applies to
attend MST in Manchester
they would be representative of the
percentage of students from Manchester
that can attend MSD so it isn't
necessarily that man that a school
district would have to budget extra for
the homeschool kids they've already
accounted for the fact that they would
be sending a certain number of students
to the CTE Center
uh but again if if the student decide
they live in they go to school in Nashua
and want to attend that Center if there
is a seat available because it wasn't
full they can be accepted and attend
there
I hope that helped okay can we take just
a short break here Eric on where you
where we're going with this sort of the
center Apprentice is trying to get in
quickly
she's got to get on some other things
and she we have her elevated in here
right now Senator Prentice can you hear
us
I certainly can representative Ladd and
thank you
um thank you for taking time out to let
me testify today and introduce
um section three
of 148 so
um members of the House Education
committee again well I think we're into
afternoon now so good afternoon my name
is suprentice I'm the state center from
District Five
um and I'm a co-sponsor
of section three and I'm standing in
today for
um Senator Gannon who represents
District 23. again to introduce part
three of 148 relative to the emergency
plans for sports related injuries by way
of background I'm a long time paramedic
and I actually started my medical career
as a student athletic trainer both in
high school and in college so I have
some background in actually working on
emergencies in in in academic athletic
setting okay currently a gap exists with
emergency plans to respond to serious or
potentially life-threatening sports
related injuries during school sponsored
activities specifically for athletes in
the public and non-public school
settings that offer Athletics for grades
4 through 12. Section 3 of 148 updates
our current law that was written in
1971. I was in the first grade and this
relay is relating to policies adopted by
local school boards for the purposes of
providing immediate and adequate
emergency care for students and
Personnel who sustain injury or illness
during school hours or during scheduled
school activities the Senate education
committee amended the language to ensure
that the emergency plans for sports
related injuries is included in the
school's overall emergency response plan
and also move the effective date to
September 1 2022 to provide District
sufficient time to develop an emergency
response plan
these changes were unanimously supported
by the committee and SB 148 was adopted
on the consent calendar in the Senate
by updating the statute this bill not
only aligns with the best practices it
standardizes emergency plans for sports
related injuries and illnesses allowing
each energy entity to be informed of the
minimum standard of care athletes will
receive in addition this bill promotes
the flexibility for each School Board to
develop appropriate plans based on their
geographic location population and
District needs it should also be noted
that the proposed Bill identifies the
public and non-public schools shall
establish procedures as part of their
plan for athletes with a confirmed
covid-19 diagnosis to return to play
which is consistent with best practice
and expert recommendations in conclusion
emergency plans are a zero cost policy
that incorporates the resources the
school already has available and can be
easily modified as the school accesses
additional resources I urge the
committee to support Section 3 of 148
Senate Bill 148. there are athletic
trainers and other stakeholders who
support this they may they have been
involved in drafting this legislation
that may be here and can speak more
directly up to the need and importance
for Statewide Baseline for emergency
action plans for sports related injuries
I appreciate your time of members of the
House Education committee uh chairlad
and if I can answer any questions I'd be
happy to
thank you very much senator now you see
what these Omnibus bills do to us you
know they totally mess with our minds
it is we find the uh the process
um challenging on the Senate side too
but just like all of us we we uh must
run through yeah I understand I
understand so what we'll do we'll allow
questions to you on this part but then
we're going to bounce back to part two
and finish up the CTE stuff uh are there
questions for uh Senator Apprentice
representative Tanner you have your hand
up yep yes yes thank you chair and thank
you Senator Prentice this is a much
needed bill
um and I think uh when you say
emergencies for sports uh related
injuries I'm hoping that this bill
extends to practices
oftentimes you have practices at odd
hours and you know as the coach you're
the only one there uh and when you have
to call for an emergency it's good to
have something like this in place so uh
I hope it it the intent is not just at
athletic events uh but also at practices
and and uh Recreation
type events great uh chair may I yes go
ahead thank you uh representative Tanner
exactly um it's been my experience that
the you know when you're having a game
and there's a crowd and a plan and all
these activities things normally run
pretty smoothly there and uh but it is
those off hours practices
um where you might have to travel a
distance to get to a phone to actually
call for help and that's a that is you
know part of what this this proposal
this legislation wants to address is
make sure that all is even regardless of
whether you're in a game or not if you
have a plan and people know what to do
um we can we can save lives and I've
actually have seen that happen on the on
the sports field so thank you thank you
for bringing this forward you are so
welcome perhaps I would talk
thank you Mr chairman thank you senator
for taking my question just I understand
that sports related is there any thought
to have this integrated with physical
education uh programs that are off-site
or at the far part of the site
physical education programs then I
missed the second part of Europe that
are at the far part of the campus
for example Fields they're out far away
and it just needs to be the physical
education uh emergency plan may be
relevant uh that's all
chair may I yes go ahead a great
question representative Woodcock that
should be integrated into the school's
already emergency response plan uh
because that covers
I don't call it that well it covers the
the day
um and all of the classes courses that
may be going on this adds the athletic
events which are often off hours and
sometimes even off campus but we also
made sure as a senate amended to put
this all in the same plan so yes to your
question we're just adding this into
that overall emergency plan thank you
sir appreciate it thank you Mr chair
you're so welcome are there further
representative your hand up again or is
it just not down it's up again uh
chairman
thank you for recognizing me I'm just um
wondering if there was any thought put
in uh
representative Woodcock County got my
mind going about extracurricular
activities that are not necessarily
sports related
um theatrical groups that that are
practicing you know late in the evening
um
the outdoor education groups
we're just talking about Environmental
Education that maybe uh you know
wouldn't necessarily be part of the
school's emergency plan but uh I know
sports are probably a little more
riskier but certainly some of the
Environmental Education has its risks as
well
chairman
yes I might add one thing for you
representative Tanner at that if you
look at RSA 193 colon 1-c or 110 Dash D
colon 3. we are not using the word
extracurricular we're using
co-curricular okay if you slice into
that also intramurals then you're
covering all activities whether it be
theater production or some other
activity that's not curricular of nature
during the same day our co-curricular
can even be during the school day
um but we've been using co-curricular
and all these areas RSA if we flip that
in rather than saying athletic because
athletic is simply a part of
co-curricular activities I think we have
a broader coverage here and be
consistent with other forms of our our
first actions
Senator do you have further
I didn't no I don't thank you
representative Ladd and and thank you
okay what we're going to do now because
we have one more question I believe
uh I did have a question uh
yes a rep sound Market uh it thank you
senator for taking my question uh I'm
just looking at how covid-19 is
specifically mentioned my question is
um what about other contagious
infectious conditions uh I'm just
wondering if Covenant being mentioned
was that
that cover similar contagious infectious
emissions
Mr chair yes go go ahead yes okay so
representative moffatt thank you for the
question I'm going to need to confirm
this but it's my understanding that I
mean covid-19 is a new infectious
contagious condition but schools have
um for we're going to just consider all
of as representative Ladd I'll just
pointed out we're going to represent
this all as one package they already
have standards
um for say return to school and or
return to play so covid-19 was added
into this to take you know to take that
extra step and make sure that it was
added onto the list that already existed
because you can't return to play you
can't return to school unless you meet a
certain criteria for a number of you
know infectious issues I can remember my
daughter when she was in school if she
had a temperature within 24 hours she
couldn't return to school it had to be
clear for that period of time
sure thank you thank you you're welcome
are there further questions out of
senator Prince
I think we're done with the questions
it's great to see a representative Ladd
and everyone and I appreciate your uh
your time this afternoon okay pretty
much and I did enjoy Hanover the other
day oh well good I'm glad you got there
safe and sound all right perfect you're
welcome
okay what we're going to do is we're
backing off to Eric on talk about the
part two the CTE I think we're going to
try to get through this part and then
we're going to take a break for lunch we
many of us been sitting here
and uh it's we need to stretch these
legs so Eric uh could you please
continue
thank you representative Evan I will
hopefully do this also very quickly uh
lunch sounds great right about now
um with regard to the transportation
question about uh Private School charter
school and homeschool students uh those
students actually have never been
included in the transportation piece
typically the the private school the
parent or the charter school has been
providing the transportation the way the
legislation is written Transportation
goes from the sending school to the CTE
Center and so unless the kid can get to
you know if a kid is attending uh
Private School uh and lives in Concord
and can get to Concord and you know or
you can get to ball high school and get
on the bus because they're a bow student
and go to go to Concord but I don't
think that's ever happened the charter
schools the private schools or the
parents of the home school students
typically bring the students directly or
they drive them to ourselves to the CTE
centers but as representative Ladd and
Senator Waters mentioned what uh some
wording chains that representative lad
and I worked on is to fix the problem
for Manchester Nashua and Exeter
that rather than using the the language
of the sending School District which is
which would eliminate those three
districts we changed it to I believe the
home school district is putting the
transportation so that will allow
Nashua to apply for reimbursement
between north and south and Manchester
in between all of the schools that are
providing to MST and for Exeter because
they are the only CTE Center not
actually located where the high school
is
uh so we did understand that that was a
challenge and uh in this legislation
we're fixing it that it will no longer
be 10 cents per mile per kid but it will
be the actual cost of the transportation
because our schools were losing uh
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
transportation because they need to
spend 750 on a bus
for four kids and they were only getting
reimbursed 10 cents per mile uh so uh we
did realize that that uh that became a
big burden so
um so we didn't fix that piece
um the only other note I actually had uh
was
now we need to find it I'm sorry I
believe it is Page four
uh as part of the construction piece uh
in an in the request in the editing of
this bill we'd asked to remove
um Part F line two where it says accept
students from sending schools as we were
discussing this with the construction in
the committee
we were reading it to say that in order
to receive funding for construction a
CTE Center must accept students from
sending schools
we have three CTE centers that do not
have any sending districts
and so as we were reading this we we
said well now they're not going to be
eligible for the renovation funds
because they don't accept sending
students
uh
after so we we all agreed and put this
through uh commissioner edelblue
interestingly read it differently
he said even though for example
Portsmouth which does not have any
sending districts if a kid from Dover
wanted to attend a program at Portsmouth
because Portsmouth had one
Portsmouth would accept them so they by
definition are accepting a sending
student
so if we if we eliminated that in here
he was afraid that although nobody would
do it a school could go great we've
accepted all this money from the state
and now we're no longer going to accept
students from sending schools so I would
respectfully ask that the committee
remove our request
okay
[Music]
represent mile are you up your hand up
yeah yes uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you Eric for taking my question how does
I have two questions
if a school district has a certain quota
that they have to send to a particular
CTE Center
and now we're adding uh private and home
school students to this
group how does the school district
determine who is going to be in that
quota if they've got more students than
the quota would allow sure uh great
question uh it is actually up the um
acceptance into a CTE Center
is up to the CTE Center
so uh and I'll I'll use Concord and bow
we I use them all the time Bo represents
say five percent of the this the
populace the way it's determined is
student population within the town
and so let's say Bo represents five
percent of the region
so when Concord does their allocations
they say there can be five percent of
our seats in all of our programs
dedicated to students
who live in Bow
now let's say that represents 75 seats
it's very possible that 110 kids from Bo
fill out applications and send them to
Concord and that would include kids who
are at Charter Schools and Etc but live
in Bow and send them to Concord
conquered decides which of the 75
students actually fill the seats so it's
not up to Beau to determine who which
applications they can include and they
send them all
so so it's the CTA Center that basically
basically makes the determination of
which students are going to participate
thanks that's a clarification I didn't
realize so the next question I have is
that dealing with the transportation
costs yes that is
um I know like in Hopkinton for example
we've got a bus that takes students into
uh the CTA Center in Concord how does
that work if and I mean does a student
from a particular residence School
District do they then have to comply
with what the transportation process is
from that school district to the CTE
Center or does the individual have a
right to get there however they want to
get there what's the procedure on that
sure so if if they're attending say
Hopkinton high school if that's the high
school they attend
then they need then it's how their
school district sends kids to the CTE
Center many of the CTE Centers do not
allow students to self-transport they
don't have the parking space for it
right this that which is why the school
districts are providing buses and which
is why the state is reimbursing the
school districts because it's an
out-of-pocket expense for a school
district that they wouldn't normally
expend but there are some instances
where uh both the CTE Center and the
High School allow a student to
self-transport they have in many
instances they have to apply there has
to be a specific reason for it
uh but in which case the student can
self-transport and then they are
reimbursed that 25 cents per mile
so just as a follow-up if I may one
final let's use the example of a of a
student
let's say from Hopkinton
uh that is going to uh the Tilton School
in a private school okay and the signs
that they want to attend a program as
part of their as part of their education
uh at the Concord CTA program how does
the transportation from a residential
student at Tilton to then come to the
con the CTA and Concord how does that
Transportation work
so uh it you you actually ask a
phenomenal question
um we have um
no I've I've never heard of of that
specific situation
um I I can tell you that any time we
have had a private school student or a
charter school student or a homeschool
student they have self-transported
whether it is a parent
or it's you know the school has a van
that drives them uh and uh so we've
never heard of uh of a challenge
otherwise uh we're happy to to try to
help figure it out
um but so far it hasn't happened
um
all right thank you for that
clarification
represent woodcock
thank you Mr chair Eric thanks for
taking my question just it's a
clarification on simple CTE uh protocol
which I don't know the answer to
um which I don't I don't know a lot of
again so this is just another one uh on
the CTE piece if a young I'm from Conway
by the way okay youngster uh lives in
Conway and wants to go to a CTE program
we have a school here right it has a
similar say uh a robotics program that
we have do they have the choice to go to
a different uh CTE or they obligated to
stay in the one they have no great
question they they do have a choice
however they will be an out of region
student
which means that they would be the last
one to get a seat in the program so if
they wanted to go to Laconia for the
program in Laconia for example once
Laconia fills all of its applicants from
its assigned Regional centers if there
are empty seats right now if there's
empty seats students at Laconia High
School typically fill those all those
empty seats but there was an out of
District student they would then be the
next one in line to fill those seats
follow up Mr chair FMA yes you may thank
you um Eric to that question I lost you
here oh there you go yeah you moved I do
okay to that question
um would the SAU 9 and where we live be
responsible with Transportation since we
have that program in our our SAU as well
um
no
uh because it is an out of region and
out of
um
that student is opting
on their own op to go out of that region
so uh they would not be obligated to pay
for the student
um but again
um
the legislation we're putting in right
now there would ultimately be no
out-of-pocket expense for the school
uh because they would be fully
reimbursed for tuition rather than the
10 cents per mile
okay
because the student made their own
personal decision to go to a different
school okay thanks again appreciate it
thank you
but thank you for bringing up great
questions
Eric I think we need some clarification
too because you're saying fully full
cost of Transportation will be
reimbursed uh you presented the council
several years ago or even the commission
that an FY 20 uh Transportation costs
that were reimbursed were 680 000 of
which the actual costs were 2.6 million
dollars yes so this is going to end up
with a significant increase in in
finances with what we're proposing here
uh yes and no
um it moved the money from one column to
another uh currently there is nine
million dollars allocated for tuition
and transportation
the way the law is written
transportation is paid first
and then whatever is left is divided by
the number of students attending CTE to
cover up to 75 percent of the tuition
costs
so yes that is correct Eric but that's
just taking from one pot distilled nine
million dollars allocated each year
and we're now going to take out of that
and throw the tuition money which is
75.25 over to the other side of the coin
so they're going to re receive
in in
actuality the same amount of money it's
but they're not going to receive the
full tuition amount
I see this we're going to have to if
we're going to do full funding we're
going to have to fully fund the
difference which is about two million
dollars I I could not agree with you
more representative and uh during the
fiscal committee hearings this was
presented uh and that conversation did
come up around increasing the TNT
allotment by at least two million
dollars
and uh I do not know where that stands I
I do not believe there was a motion to
increase that amount but that was the
request well I see representative Heath
here maybe she can help us out
yes thank thank you chairman lad um
during our negotiations in division two
about TNT we actually wanted to raise it
um but the question I believe from the
doe was that if we raise that amount in
the level of Maintenance of effort you
would have trouble meeting that in the
following years so that's why we ended
up not increasing because we had talked
about raising the T because we wanted to
get it funded to the level that it
should be funded can you give me any
information on that uh the at you are
correct that that was the question to me
was uh would this uh the maintenance of
effort and I I said it would and it
would raise the maintenance of effort in
perpetuity so the concern that I
understood that came back from Finance
was
we would putting the state in a position
of me basically requiring them to keep
it at that new higher level moving
forward and the committee wasn't sure
they could lock themselves into
requiring a future budget to keep it at
that new elevated 11 million if I
remember correctly and so we we left it
at the um the rate that we had
established initially for that reason
because we didn't want to
um cause a hardship in terms of
Maintenance of effort you know whether
or not there was going to be future
funding
um but it's disappointing that we
couldn't raise that level because I
think there there is an issue because it
ends up getting prorated across the
state
yes
that is correct
and that's yeah
it's not helping and then if we add
Nashua Exeter
in Manchester into the transportation
pot uh obviously uh if we're going to
maintain the policy that we all believe
in there's going to have to be some
matching dollars to support that policy
uh Eric do you have anything else for us
on on this these changes
um I don't uh I just thank thank you all
for for bringing all these changes
forward and I said I do know you and I
spoke that uh that you have a couple
other
um technical edits to put in which I
appreciate okay thank you we'll deal
with those later all right thank you so
much
um and I know um I'm gonna be leaving as
well so uh just to let you know with
regard to The Outdoor Rec piece uh CTE
is already working on the inclusion of
outdoor represent outdoor uh Recreation
management as programs and competencies
within our program so
um so the request that's in the
legislation for us to present on it in
2022 we will not have any concerns with
uh thank you very much Eric and have a
good lunch
thank you you all too
uh do we have anybody else that wants to
talk on this part because of the other
parts we're gonna have to wind up a
little bit after we
okay so we we have basically done this
second part
um
uh and we there are five charts this
bill uh I don't believe we've talked
about the uh Vocational Rehabilitation
which is part one
uh nor are we we got into police
part three and part five
and and uh I believe Dave Waters talked
about the part five you know
what store was it let's see no nobody's
talked about
our 40th
oh except uh Senator Waters he just
introduced it
so
um
we can keep driving through this thing
um but or we can take a half hour break
what are what's the uh
the feeling of those on the committee
see where we are okay uh any anybody
objecting to go through the one o'clock
let's drive okay good
okay so
um
do we have anybody uh sign up to speak
on part one let's get that
uh people have not signed up in a
is there anybody out there that's an
attendee that would like to speak to
part one
of this bill SB 148 if so please put
your hand up okay we do have one person
who just has their hand raised they're
not signed up but we can unmute them
mute the individual and and have any
okay sorry uh Lisa Henson hatz I'm The
Vocational Rehabilitation director from
the Department of Education
um thank you
um uh representative Ladd and committee
uh for allowing me to speak um I did
sign up this morning I apologize for not
being on the roster earlier
um what I did wanted to say in terms of
part one is that vocational
rehabilitation uh has been undergoing a
whole host of changes and one of those
uh has been updating our administrative
rules and as we reviewed our
administrative rules through both
internal review as well as a legislative
budget assistant internal audit this
last couple years there were several
areas of our administrative rules that
were identified needing update and so we
were able to update those and what you
see in in the language in this bill are
some areas that we needed to repeal and
the primary reason for that is that
either they're no longer administered by
the program and administered by some
other party or they're just not programs
that are available any longer and so
that is uh that is the reason for that
language within the bill and I would
certainly be willing to take any
questions that anyone has uh on any part
in there
thank you very much Miss hatch is
h-a-t-z right yes yeah
um thank you very much are there any
questions regarding part one now
so it sounds like it's an administ
administrative changes to try and get
current
yep
okay
thank you very much
IES
I can see I don't think we have taken
questions on part three
so are there any is there anybody out
there in the attendee list that would
like to testify on part three of SB 148
if so would you please raise your hand
Mr chair maybe I hope we do have someone
I was going to say maybe it would be
helpful to talk about the content of the
building the sports injuries
hello there can you all hear me yes we
can okay
well um good afternoon honorable members
of the committee thank you for having me
today I'm excited
um to be here with you to talk about
this bill
um as you already heard my name is
Rebecca Stearns I am the CEO of the
Corey Stringer Institute and I'm here
today representing the institute's full
support for part three of SB 148
emergency action plans for sports so the
mission
um of the Corey Stringer Institute is to
provide research education advocacy and
consultation for to maximize performance
optimize safety and ultimately prevent
Sun death for the athlete war fighter
and labor and so our goal is to reduce
catastrophic injuries related to the top
causes of death and there are four
conditions that really make up over 90
of the sudden deaths that we see in
athletes
and this includes Cardiac Arrest
exertional heat stroke traumatic head
injuries and exertional sickling and
just those four do make up 90 of the
deaths that we see
and so if you look at the years between
or the five years between 2015 and 2019
we lost about 335 athletes high school
athletes lives in the U.S just to these
sudden cardiac or sudden events
and so it even though we did lose those
athletes we do believe that through
State policy requirements we are
confident that more athletes can go home
to their families and their parents at
the end of the night so this bill
specifically enacts five vital health
and safety components that benefit the
high school athletes in the state of New
Hampshire so I'm just going to go
through those very briefly the first
um is mandating emergency action plans
and so just alone having an emergency
action plan and a plan in place when a
catastrophic injury does happen improves
the survival of cardiac events by 35
and so part of having an emergency
action plan also includes other
components which are supported by this
bill one of them being outlining the
automated external defibrillator access
and we know that each year one in 36
high schools will have a student who
suffers a cardiac arrest and survival
rates are currently around 54 at the
high school level for athletes who
suffer Cardiac Arrest however in cases
where there is an AED and it's used we
know that the survival rate is is as
high as 89 percent
and then another policy included in the
bill would be related to having a
Weather policy and specifically a wet
bulb Globe temperature policy and this
policy has resulted in over 35 percent
reduction in heat exhaustion cases when
it is mandated
a heat acclimatization policy is also
included and we've seen where a heat
acclimatization policy is mandated and
it's provided a 55 reduction in heat
illnesses
and lastly it includes Provisions for a
cold water immersion policy we know that
cold water immersion can save 100 of the
heat stroke victims when it's applied
within 15 minutes
so all of these are established best
practices and policies that are
supported by Leading sport health and
safety organizations such as the
national athletic trainers Association
and the American College of sports
medicine
there are over 120 schools in New
Hampshire and we know that about 42
percent of those are almost 9 000
students don't have access to an
athletic trainer and this is the typical
medical provider who creates and
implements these policies so it makes it
that much more vital to have these laws
to ensure basic health and safety policy
is implemented for all athletes
so even even for those schools that do
have athletic trainers we do know that
gaps in these policies still exist our
most recent survey showed that there are
almost 4 000 New Hampshire athletes at a
school with an athletic trainer but
there's no established emergency action
plan so that obviously is why this bill
could allow for equal health and safety
protection across all athletes in the
state so it is our hope that through the
continued adoption of best practices
we'll continue to see reductions in the
senseless sport related deaths so each
of the topic areas that I've addressed
today are currently legislated in at
least one or more other states for
example seven states have legislation
that every school in their state have an
emergency action plan 15 other states
have language to support aeds in
athletic venues nine of which were
adopted just in the last five years
alone
and I just like to point out that in
addition if this still if this bill does
pass the Corey Stringer Institute is
part of its grant program that is
sponsored by the national athletic
trainers Association and the NFL we'll
be coordinating a meeting in New
Hampshire with leaders
um that are responsible for high school
sport health and safety to compile and
prepare all the resources to help
support successful implementation of
these policies
so adopting this bill would provide
necessary and basic policies to ensure
that no other athletes lives are
needlessly lost
so thank you again for your attention
today I'd be happy to answer any
questions
thanks very much for your testimony are
there
are there questions from the committee
not seeing any hands thank you very much
do we have
[Music]
um
foreign
hello
yeah hi good afternoon thank you
committee for uh for allowing me to
speak on this topic of uh SB 148.
um as I've been an athletic trainer um
for uh several years um I'm the
president-elect of the State of New
Hampshire
um and I wanted to speak on this in a
couple of different aspects uh number
one uh having dealt with a lot of uh
severe injuries and things uh that have
come up in my career both Collegiate and
high school
um I see that knowing having people know
where to go what to do how to react
um is a major thing and it helps to
prevent as you as as was mentioned
earlier
um some severe injuries and different
things that happen my point that I want
to speak on this comes to the point
where if we can get this passed I want
to make sure that it's very well known
that we need to not drop the ball after
it's passed and after schools go ahead
and write these policies that they make
sure that these policies are readdressed
you know yearly or in a timely manner
because I can see that things get
written addressed that we always change
we have different coaches we have
different athletic trainers we have
different administrators and they all
come through and if it's not addressed
on a regular basis I think things get
lost
um and it's as simple as as people
knowing that you stand at the end of X
Road and have somebody there waving down
the ambulance to point them in the
direction to where they need to go
um so on that point that I mean that's
my main point is yes I'd love to see the
bill pass I think it'll be a huge uh
Plus for the State of New Hampshire for
the Athletics Association things like
that but I want to make sure that we
stay on top of it to be able to allow
um schools to regulate and make sure
that as you change coaches as you change
people they are aware of it and that's
part of their normal procedure of moving
in
um it's just as important it is to learn
your team and and learn all the
different administrative things that
happen at a school you need to learn
that there's an emergency action plan
and you need to be a part of it in order
to make it a success I don't want to
take up any more time I know that you
guys are have been really pushing
through and getting for lunch but uh
address any questions if anybody has
them thank you very much are there any
questions
yes represent Shaw can you
um identify yourself
oh my name is Leonard Angeli I'm the
president-elect of the national of the
New Hampshire athletic trainers
Association actually just number two on
our list
and I'm also
yeah we've got it thank you are there
any uh other questions for Leonard
thank you very much for hanging with us
and and testifying today
okay so what with that we're going to
close this section part three and move
on to part four
which deals with a definition of product
post-secondary Career School
yeah
there's there's several there now
okay
I love you
hello can you hear me yes we can welcome
I'm sorry I just got booted off after
being on for hours and then my turn to
talk
um actually since Senator Ward is not
available would it be possible for
Shannon Roche to go before me because
she has some background information that
will be important before I do my
testimony
okay
welcome to education
wonderful can you all hear me yes we can
wonderful thank you so much and thank
you
um my name is Shannon roach and I serve
as the president and chief executive
officer of yoga Alliance we are the
largest nonprofit Association
representing yoga teachers almost all of
whom operate as small businesses or sole
proprietorships we're also proud to
count 35 yoga schools and 478 yoga
teachers in New Hampshire among our
members so again thank you for the
opportunity to speak in support of
Senate Bill 148 part uh part four as you
know the existing law authorizes the
Department of Education to the licensed
businesses that provide occupational
Training importantly the the licenses do
not necessarily apply to every business
in the state that offers skills
instruction or Advanced education but
rather programs that are occupational in
nature late last year for the first time
the department began began requiring
some yoga providers who offer advanced
yoga programs which are sometimes known
in the yoga Community as quote unquote
yoga teacher trainings to become
licensed this raised two concerns for
our small business members
first the licensure requirements and
fees were were undulube burdened to
small businesses especially in a time of
covet divorce and second yoga programs
in this case have been mischaracterized
as career schools we we yoga lines
brought these concerns to the department
and we very much appreciate their
dialogue through that dialogue and our
discussions we learned that a primary
concern of the Departments is consumer
protection meaning ensuring that
individuals who enroll in and spend
money on certain kinds of programs would
be protected if a school can't or
doesn't deliver for some reason we
certainly agree with the need to protect
consumers and as such of course we
support Senate Bill 148 because the
legislation squarely addresses the
concerns of the yoga Community broadly
of small businesses and as we understand
it of the department first the
legislation exempts those small
businesses with an annual birth tuition
of 100 000 or less from licensure
requirements we understand that this
exemption is supported by officials in
the department and reflects and we feel
it reflects the burden of licensure on
small businesses and second the
legislation exempts instructional
programs for teaching Fitness and
recreational Wellness but also provides
that any entity with a gross annual
income of over one hundred thousand
dollars from those programs would obtain
a surety bond this provision recognizes
legitimate consumer protection concerns
by requiring those large yoga programs
to obtain a surety bond just like all
the other programs licensed by the
department
but at the same time the provision
recognizes that advanced yoga classes
are not in fact career schools while
these advanced classes as I mentioned
are often called teacher trainings in
our community the name is somewhat of a
misnomer because the classes are not
actually
prerequisite for teaching yoga to others
and because most individuals by their
own sort of reporting participate in
these programs to deepen their personal
practice or to practice yoga in a group
setting and I'll just take one 30
seconds to help maybe understand what I
mean by deepening one's personal
practice it's a little bit of a term of
Art in our community
so just to help sort of set the ground
there I'd like to just share that you
know the common understanding of yoga as
a type of exercise that may involve
specific poses or great flexibility
um is is sort of is insufficient and
incomplete in fact yoga is actually a
philosophical or some considerative
spiritual discipline for which the
postures themselves are just a method of
observing the teachings the advanced
yoga programs are a vehicle for those
who wish to learn more about those other
components to do so so that's what I
mean when I say deepening one's personal
practice it's really sort of a study
session
um and then just to share that you know
for those handful of folks who do go
through the program to teach and who
eventually go on to teach very few of
them teach yoga as their primary career
or singular source of income
so just you know in to close I would say
the licensure requirements for private
post-secondary career schools are simply
a bad fit for yoga programs for these
programs in particular and are Geared
for more Traditional School settings and
educational programs the licensure
application for example asks for
admission requirements the school's
policy on the transfer of credits an
overview of curriculum offerings and a
description of the school's grading
system among many other requirements
which simply aren't applicable to these
kinds of programs
exempting advanced yoga programs from
the state's private post-secondary
Career School laws would align with how
most other states treat these programs
as well the majority do not license yoga
teacher training programs quote unquote
as career schools for these reasons we
ask that you support Senate Bill 148 and
I'm happy to take any questions the
committee might have and I again would
just really like to thank you for your
time
thank you very much Shannon are there
any questions
or Shannon just real quick Rick yes go
ahead Dave thanks thanks very much Mr
chair and thanks very much Ms Roche for
joining us this afternoon
um I'm I'm interested where did you uh
where did you hear or where did you
learn that the um primary role of the
Department of Education is consumer
protection
just forgive me if I misspoke the I
don't think that the primary role is
consumer protection but my understanding
from conversations we had with with
relevant representatives in the
department who would be overseeing the
implementation of this provision is that
one of their concerns that that sort of
prompted this provision in the first
place was one of consumer protection
so I believe my comment was meant to be
specific to that office okay no thank
you I I certainly agree with your um
your statements uh with respect to um
um you know the intention of the primary
and secondary Career Development being
really you know beyond the scope of of
of
um of Wellness um training so thank you
thank you uh further questions
not seeing any hands thank you very much
now we can go back to Maureen
hi thank you very much um I was actually
the first yoga school first I'll
introduce myself my name is Maureen
Miller and I'm the owner of yoga NH it's
a business that has led yoga classes and
trainings and events throughout New
Hampshire since 2004. though I currently
live in Dover I lived in Concord for 25
years and I had my business in the
capital city for 14 of those years
although I'm here to tell you about my
story related to this particular Bill I
know that I speak on behalf of many
other yoga businesses so thank you so
much for your time I was the first
school that the first yoga business that
the doe reached out to and it was very
clear in those conversations that it was
related to consumer protection around
Financial
concerns related to students if they had
any issues and in my years of doing
business there have never been any
issues and when we were on our cynic
call the Senate even stated that when
they that in their mind they didn't know
of any uh they act they actually asked
the doe if there had been any issues
related to student protection related to
financial concerns for yoga business and
they said no as Shannon said right now
some of the career schools
you know yoga really just doesn't fit
it's like CPAs I'm looking at my list of
what I found on the department of Ed
last night electrical technology
computer technology lnas dental
assistants these are truly careers where
people take the program to become
proficient in that profession and the
yoga business that's not the norm in my
16 years of leading yoga programming
I've had hundreds of graduates and they
have been primarily to deepen their yoga
practice and in fact many of the people
who have taken our trainings I know that
um Katie will speak after me about some
of the experience she had with leading
some trainings they have included
doctors nurses physical therapists
lawyers social workers even one of your
fellow Representatives has graduated
from my teacher training program they
have other careers that are their
Mainstay to profession and they do this
to deepen their practice to learn more
about yoga to share with their family
and friends and to deepen their own
spirituality and that's really just you
know in our mind a fancy word for
learning about living life on and off
the yoga mat and just really exploring
more deeply so
um let's see what else I wanted to say
that a lot of times people who take the
bus take of the program they have other
businesses they have other jobs we
already established that even though
I've had my business for 16 years I
worked for UNH for 15 of those years and
currently I'm a finance director at a
non-profit and the reason why I
mentioned that is we are not doing this
to make money in that particular career
we have other careers and this sort of
augment stuff for purposes that are
important to us more related to a hobby
as opposed to a career and
in terms of the consumer protection
programs and regulations in New
Hampshire yoga businesses are required
to
follow the law around any consumer
protection laws that there are that are
outside of the scope of this doe bill so
we really support Senate Bill 148 and I
thank you so much for your time if you
have any questions thank you very much
are there any questions for Maureen
Miller
not see any hands up thank you very much
foreign
thank you so much I'm I'm really pleased
to be here and happy to speak on this uh
and our support of FB 148 part four so
again thank you very much for hearing
um what I have to share my name is Katie
O'Connell and I own dragonfly yoga Barn
which is way up here in North Sandwich
New Hampshire actually really more
central part of the state I've been
practicing yoga for over 20 years and I
have been teaching yoga in New Hampshire
since 2003 my husband and I relocated a
275 year old barn from moultonborough
just down the road and put it up here in
Sandwich so part of our business
actually really is founded on
maintaining the the natural landscape
and incorporating that into our business
which is I think really cool
um that's also the same year that I
finished teaching 15 years as a public
school teacher in the state of New
Hampshire so after rebuilding our
antique barn I opened up my studio I
left my Public School teaching job and
I've been teaching here at dragonfly for
the past 12 years in my small town
locals and out-of-staters alike have
often called dragonfly my business the
heart of the community we offer a
variety of programs to serve our local
popular population it's always been a
bit of a hustle and I think this is an
important piece that I want to impart to
create a program that are you know
really meet a broad population here
where I am in Sandwich I've always worn
many hats to keep dragonfly yoga Barnes
doors open and this has really never
been truer than it is right now I have
been closed for the past 16 months as a
business and I've done all of my
teaching online the same way that we are
in this meeting right now on Zoom so
um getting my doors back open is really
important and yoga teacher training
programs are a part of what I do
um I am here to express my strong belief
that imposing licensure on yoga teacher
training programs in New Hampshire will
negatively impact not only my studio as
a small business in the state but other
Studios like mine that offer
life-changing studies in yoga and
exactly as Maureen was suggesting
the financial burden of licensure with
its additional expenses not only puts
the ability of Studio owners like me who
offer training programs in Jeopardy but
quite frankly the fees also have the
capacity to close the doors of some
small businesses like mine that do
piecemeal together a lot of different
threads to make up what one might
actually call a reasonable living we
don't really
you know in the yoga world we don't
really call our earnings a salary
there's really no such thing
um this is problematic for small
businesses like mine who run only one
training per year and rely on multiple
streams of income to remain open and
that's my situation personally you've
already heard from Maureen and Shannon
about their broad experiences Maureen in
particular as a teacher and a business
owner in New Hampshire and I would
second every note that they both shared
and punctuate Maureen's point that most
of our yoga students come to us after
years of personal practice and most
often to deepen their own practice of
self which really is that body mind
spirit and they elect to engage in a
personal development training like ours
to that end
I also want to note that I have been an
adjunct faculty member at Plymouth State
University and a high school English
teacher in the state of New Hampshire
for 15 years I I completed my my work in
the public sector of Education
um gosh 12 years ago now since I opened
my business here so I can personally
attest to the difference between
training students for a career and what
it means to share and teach programs
that are intended for personal growth
and development like what I'm doing now
and a yoga teacher training is certainly
the latter a rare few will ever call
yoga a career I don't think I've ever
heard any of my colleagues use that word
most yoga teachers do not receive
salaries they would not call yoga
training a standalone income yoga
teaching a standalone income I think
most of us do it because we love it and
because we know how beneficial it is for
people in our community to practice yoga
and finally those who go on to share
yoga with others rarely leave another
job solely to teach yoga as Maureen
suggested it's just simply not feasible
for most of us to do that additionally
many students who study with us do go
back to their communities to offer yoga
and meditation and and other rounds of
yoga by donation oftentimes and often to
underserved populations at-risk
communities and even to colleagues at
their real job you know where corporate
folks might be actually making a salary
yoga is starting to you know move into
these Realms and with really good reason
and great effect
um this is where we can alleviate stress
tension help knit people into
fellowships that promote overall
Wellness
and I would also say that our teachers
have brought to their respective
communities practices that can really
only be seen as enrichment and that
serve the human Spirit as well as really
important right now boost our immune
system
after the stress of the past year I
would argue that really what we all need
is more yoga and taking yoga schools out
of this designation as a career program
will certainly help that endeavor in my
opinion and I believe the opinion of my
colleagues here so again with so much
gratitude just thank you for the
opportunity to share today
thank you very much Katie yeah we can
Alicia your hand is up yeah
yeah I just had a question
um
do you know if there are any uh schools
entities whatever that have a gross
annual income of over a hundred thousand
in the state that's directly a treatable
to instruction
Etc you know is there anybody who
actually would need to have a surety
bond in the state of New Hampshire as
you know representative I'm not sure if
you're if you're asking me or or anybody
else in this body who can answer it
I am unaware of of other the specific
financials of other schools
um I just know that most of the schools
and the the colleagues of mine that I am
aware of and work with most of them do
not have those kinds of figures in their
yoga teacher training programs no
thank you I think what we like to do are
there any further questions for Katie
right now we can get an answer from
Steve Appleby possibly on from the
Department of Education
one
maybe really quickly
I just wanted to say hi Katie I've taken
everybody should should have a retreat
with you if you uh want to make that
happen
thank you Deborah I do I recognize your
face and it's been a while but thank you
it's so good to see you have a good day
you as well
[Music]
um any further questions for Katie
thank you very much enjoy it up there in
the
sandwich area
alrighty
um
let's do Steve Appleby and see if he
hasn't answered that question for
representative
serious
good afternoon now thank you Steve
Appley
division director at the Department of
Education
um
the direct answer to the question
representative regarding did you mean
yoga schools over a hundred thousand
dollars in annual gross tuition or
schools in general this is my question
back
um the in the thing it specifies
uh gross annual income over a hundred
thousand etc etc
um would provide need to provide a
surety bond and I'm just wondering if we
have anybody that actually fits into
that we would actually need to provide
yep okay so um I can tell you that
Statewide we currently license about 65
schools and of that 65 about a dozen are
under 100 000 in annual gross tuition
and these schools span everything from
electrician computer dog training
various types of vocations
as far as specifically yoga schools I
don't know of any at this moment however
we only license a small handful
currently and they're all relatively
small schools that are under a hundred
thousand
so my follow-up is is there any reason
why we need to have that section in
there
um if it's fine for smaller schools to
not put up a surety why do larger
um so
the uh the
let me back up so section M makes
perfect sense to exempt
the schools with annual gross tuition of
under a hundred thousand that would
remove the burden from our smallest
schools which are as one of the um
Witnesses mentioned these are all small
businesses and this would eliminate the
450 annual fee that they paid currently
as well as their need to have a surety
bond which at that level probably cost
them several hundred dollars a year as
well to maintain
um and the next section
is is somewhat redundant and we're
actually a little concerned with the
Department that the way it is worded
might require us to actually
license more schools not less schools
and let me tell you what I mean by that
the word in currently used in the
statute
speaks of vocational education
this wording entities offering
instructional programming courses for
teaching Fitness and recreational
Wellness
it doesn't speak at all there about
vocational training it so what we're
worried about is that fitness clubs that
teach classes
to people
um under the guise of potentially them
you know conducting various types of
classes again not a vocation but
um this exists currently in the state so
we're a little concerned that this
wording actually expands the scope not
um limits the scope
and I think that would be contrary to
the goal of this legislation
so do you see a problem with taking n
out completely
we do not and that would be
that would be my recommendation
um but
of course that's what's up to the
legislature but it seemed to be
expanding the net knot not reeling it in
thank you very much
uh Steve can you please explain to me uh
or give me some examples of what these
vocational schools would be that uh you
alluded to some others there just
briefly can you go through some of the
you know the areas which we're talking
about
yes sure thank you for the question
representative live uh as I said we
license about 65 schools in areas as
diverse as pet grooming we have several
schools that teach people how to be
professional pet groomers
we also have a number of schools that
teach
individuals various computer occupations
so computer programming systems
engineering we have schools that have
electrician components we have schools
that have
[Music]
uh uh massage training again instructing
individuals how to become massage
teachers
so really it's a variety we have several
bartending schools that teach people how
to be professional bartenders
so
it really covers a lot of ground and I
would also just like to add in if I
could represent Atlantic we do
occasionally have a precipitous School
closure and we recently back in December
had a school close in Manchester New
Hampshire a nursing school
and their sudden closure because of the
surety bond that we require
approximately 690 000 in tuition is
being refunded to students who couldn't
so although it doesn't come up that
that's that's the information that's
worth our attention that you know when
somebody closes then
to have the the bond to support somebody
that's already paid that tuition sort of
so are there further questions for Steve
yes uh represent like this yes so
um following on that discussion then
foreign
would that surety bond still be required
for all of those other things and we're
just taking out the part for the yoga
instructors
yes
um what this would do is it would merely
eliminate the requirement for schools
that have less than a hundred thousand
dollars a year
in annual gross tuition it would remove
the requirement for them to be licensed
and the associated requirement of surety
bond but everybody who has higher
Revenue than a hundred thousand per year
would in fact still need to get a surety
bond and get licensed
any further questions of the Department
of Education
uh thank you Mr chair and and thank you
Mr Apple FB
um so a lot of yoga centers are called
ashrams and they are actually
religious as well as as training schools
um
how do we differentiate between
schools that teach yoga
like an ashram
or even a yoga instructor and
other religious schools that in fact
have education that may be like a
carpenter uh carpentry
education not as part of their religious
Mission
um I think we're getting into a really
slippery slope with with all this trying
to certify all these small uh different
types of of schools
or I would put quote schools on it uh
for people that are trying to get into
these
either
secondary jobs or their their Hobbies uh
you know and and we're not so worried
about private colleges
that maybe don't have a surety bond with
them so how do you make the
differentiation between
religious education and
um ashrams or places where they actually
train for yoga
thank you for the question
representative Tanner that it is a
slippery slope I would concur
um we look to the current statutes as
our guide right now and the distinction
that we make is
is this program vocational in nature so
in the example of a yoga School am I
teaching my students yoga
and whatever goes along with that
curriculum or am I teaching my students
how to be yoga teachers
that is the difference just practicing
yoga is avocation
learning how to teach other people yoga
that I could then earn a living from
that's vocational and that's what we
have articulated in the in the statute
and that's how we look at this so it
doesn't make the statute does not
delineate between for-profit or
non-profit does not delineate between
secular or religious if a religious
organization were to decide to um start
training massage therapists
how to become massage therapists
they would
see they would need to be licensed if
you know if the hundred thousand
Amendment here goes in if they did you
know had more than a hundred thousand
dollars a year in Revenue they would
need to get licensed whether they're
religious entity or not because they're
can I have a follow-up yes you may
representative Tanner so what about
internships or people who learn to
Barber now that we've passed that law uh
or trying to suppose they are doing
internships with their parents and maybe
some of the kids come in uh and they're
teaching them a vocation I mean
Boy Scouts teach vocation to some level
you know
um I just I I think
I just have a hard time
with this whole uh sort of you know
licensing issue uh of these smaller
groups uh you know the the people are
thank you representative um there wasn't
a question in that so it was more of a
comment sorry yeah I was just if I could
just um I would note that
um I it's our position this legislation
actually will help those smallest of
businesses by setting the bar to 100 000
a year currently they all have to get a
license now
the entities that have annual gross
tuition of under 100
000 will be Exempted from licensure so
um to your to your point I don't have an
answer either to your comment but
um that's
that's the conversation it's been a
thank you representative Tanner and uh
Mr Appleby I can remember we had this
discussion uh in this committee at least
12 years ago with Dr Ed McKay when we
were talking about post-secondary career
schools and and
um those uh institutions that were
putting the sign out front saying school
and then the the customer or the
individual walking down the street says
well here's a license or approved School
um how do we guarantee now that
somebody's not going to put the signed
School up in front and and have an
income of less a hundred thousand
dollars but you know
um
if the person on the street is not going
to know whether that's a licensed school
or not is there is this
um do they get licensure without having
to pay this 450 bucks or or how's that
work
or is it needed
uh thank you so
um the
if the current statute not
notwithstanding this amendment to the
statute the current statute is
anyone that's that's conducting classes
that are vocational in nature they call
themselves a school an Institute uh
those individuals would need to seek
licensure
from the department and one of the
requirements is that they publicly
display that license typically in their
Lobby or waiting area
so that that license is displayed
publicly
and we also ask that to be in their
catalog
their catalog can be online it can be
printed
but we ask that they also put down that
they are licensed by the Department of
Education and if there are student
complaints they direct them to the
so I'll follow up so if they have a
gross income a gross tuition income of
less than a hundred thousand dollars can
um per this if this legislation were to
foreign
thank you
further questions of the department
not seeing any hands
thank you very much Mr Appleby do we
have any other folks on part four
uh actually we have
Four Hands raised
people who have
previously spoken
yeah we will not be taking people at
previous is not a discussion that's a
testimony so we won't take anybody to
that's testified before unless it's a
a senator trying to qualify something so
uh Maureen Marston I believe we have not
her
okay there we go
um representative Vlad and members of
the uh House Education committee I'm
very obviously not Senator Ward and very
obviously not Marie Marston I'm Griffin
Roberge
very sorry members of the committee um
Senator Ward is currently in caucus and
uh her his her assistant is helping
other people at the moment
um Senator Ward asks that I read into
the record uh her written testimony for
part four of Samuel 148 uh would that be
okay with the members of the committee
that would be fine
part four of Senate Bill 148 deals with
a problem that came to our attention
because of the very limited uh I'm sorry
very broad wording of what a
post-secondary career school is under
our law which is capturing programs not
intended to require the strict licensing
and other requirements listed in RSA
188-g it came to our attention that
programs like yoga instruction were
recently deemed by the Department of
Education to require
post-secondary education licensure which
is placing a costly uh burden
administrative compliance and oversight
that doesn't fit within that profession
RSA 188g lists uh Department of
Education oversight to include the
premise I'm sorry the premises the
curriculum teaching materials faculty
performance sales literature financial
data and other matters which are
relevant
the law is structured to cover more
formal educational institutions like
nursing and truck driving schools that
actually have curriculum and credits and
a degree the recent interpretation is
placing requirements that make most
small yoga programs prohibitive from
even being in business
with the help of the yoga industry and
the Department of Education part four is
good pro-small business legislation that
removes an obstacle that is harming New
Hampshire businesses it has two pieces
first it carves out of the law all very
small businesses that take in under a
hundred thousand dollars of income
secondly for wellness programs like yoga
if they earn more than a hundred
thousand dollars from teaching they must
still obtain the bond requirement that
is in the current law to give consumers
protection in the event of business
ceases operating and collected income in
advance of the program
um that is the written testimony that
Senator Ward wished me to share with the
members of the committee
um I respectfully would not like to take
any questions because I do not wish to
speak much more for Senate award at this
time
thank you very much dude does do you
have a written testimony that you can
get to our clerk here I will have her
assistant email it to you and the other
members of the committee thank you very
much
thank you very much representative hey
have a good one you too
okay we're going to then we have nobody
else that has not spoken uh regarding
part four so we are going to now move on
to the last part of this bill I'll
Senate Bill 148 uh part 5. and I would
like to ask that any member of the
public that's an attendee would you
please put your hand up if you'd like to
speak to part five of
of uh SB
148 which deals with environmental and
assistant
foreign
thank the members of the committee for
their time today and with respect to
everyone's time I'm going to abridge my
remarks uh but I've submitted full
comments which I invite you to review
outside of the hearing
uh my name is Jason Seaman I live in
Durham and work as an associate
professor of outdoor leadership and
management in the recreation management
and policy department at unh
although before I share my comments that
I'm sharing my own personal and
professional views today and not
necessarily those of the University
I'm a lifelong New Hampshire resident
and have long pursued outdoor recreation
in many corners of the state moreover I
used to work at the school and District
levels in just the kinds of programs
that section 5 of SB 148 would support
and I now study outdoor education how
outdoor education and Recreation
supports Youth Development so I'm very
pleased to see SB 148 before you today
some of the recent papers my colleagues
and I have published it have published
indicate how youth from Northern New
Hampshire participate in outdoor
activities at higher rates than their
peers Nationwide the most highly
involved youth not only reports stronger
connections to their communities they
also show more favorable post-secondary
aspirations and after graduation attend
college at higher rates
our research also suggests
unsurprisingly the rural youth evaluate
their post-secondary options in light of
their perceived opportunities for
education and employment
in short youth can learn to love the
outdoors like I did as a kid growing up
here but if there aren't viable
opportunities for work along with ways
to imagine yourself doing that work it's
tough to know where to channel that
interest and that passion
fortunately the state is now wisely
investing in outdoor recreation economic
development in order to capitalize on
the true New Hampshire Advantage our
abundant outdoor amenities and strong
outdoor culture
this is why SB 148 is so critical and
why I am compelled to comment today it
can help connect those dots outdoor
recreation as a growing economic engine
on the one hand and the outdoors is a
powerful venue for forming
post-secondary aspirations on the other
hand SB 148 will help schools and youth
serving agencies align Behind These
important state priorities and build a
thriving citizenry and Workforce in New
Hampshire whether directly in the
outdoor recreation economy or in other
careers
I think it is helpful to consider SB 148
not merely as an education bill but as
an investment in the state's future
Workforce and in the future adults who
are committed to sustaining its quality
of life
in some my comments have not focused on
this on any specific learning outcomes
our schools per se
but I want to emphasize the aspects of
the outdoors that support who people are
and who they can become I can personally
attest to the strong intergenerational
bonds to New Hampshire that are promoted
through early exposure to the outdoors
and my research also shows how this
influences the way young people think
about their futures
that's why I'm asking you to think about
SB 148 as an investment into the future
of New Hampshire where opportunities are
coming together to meet real educational
outdoor and economic needs by promoting
greater outdoor involvement among New
Hampshire youth thank you again for your
time
appreciate it thank you very much are
I I do have one question for you
um at UNH where you you are a professor
um do they have a Parks and Recreation
or do they have a recreation department
which helps students be get into the
careers associated with outdoor
recreation or indoor Recreation as well
we do that's my department where it's
it's called the recreation management
and Policy Department uh and we have
three three what we call major options
so it's one major with three different
options students can elect to elect to
choose uh one is therapeutic recreation
uh and the another is program and event
management so Festival planning and
those types of careers and that often
aligns with the hospitality and tourism
Industries and then the the newest
development in that department is my
option which is the Outdoor leadership
and management department option and
that uh service students who want to go
either into uh outdoor guiding or
outdoor leadership type positions or
even parks and protected areas
management so uh yes sir that that
that's the department that I work in uh
it sounds like a wonderful experience
thank you
um are there questions from the
committee
not seeing hands thank you very much for
last person uh that I show is Janice
Crawford I'm going to promote her to
panelists
welcome Janice to education Florida
police
hey thank you
well uh you all deserve a huge Applause
for your work and your ability to sit
through this I this is my first time so
I sat through the entire thing only to
have this opportunity to speak on part
five
um so I really feel for you and
appreciate you thank you so much for the
work you do to serve the state uh my
name is Janice Crawford I am the
executive director of the Mount
Washington Valley Chamber of Commerce I
was a CTE teacher back in the early 80s
at the region uh nine Vocational School
in in Wolfeboro it was one of my most
favorite jobs and I am now a trustee of
the Northeast Waldorf Education
Foundation and I am really speaking for
myself I did learn a lot listening to
people so to make sure that I'm not I
don't get in trouble for advocating
where I shouldn't Advocate I I'm going
to say that um I don't uh I don't have a
thought either way I think that's what
the people before me said
um but I do want to encourage you to
support part five of this bill primarily
because up here in the North country as
was identified by one of the
representatives or maybe it was the
senator
we have a huge outdoor recreation
industry and we also need more people to
consider the workforce opportunities
that that provides even if it's not
their actual career but their volunteer
service such as the Avalanche group the
rescue group The stewardship of trails
working with the different organizations
that are putting millions of dollars
into the trails and volunteering for
that is so important and to create that
desire I think that outdoor education
and Environmental Education is very very
important to help the students to
understand the value of the world that
they live in especially up here if
they're going to make their lives up
here
oftentimes they do leave but we find
that they come back so being able to
share that with them so that they begin
to have a respect and a desire to
protect where we live is very very
important as my role as a trustee of the
first public charter school that is
Waldorf inspired and outdoor educated
education I can attest to the value of
outdoor education for the students for
their desire to come to school the
ability to stay outside and learn from
the environment has been very key it is
part of our curriculum but of course now
with covid uh you've seen many many many
schools have picked up on the idea of
outdoor education so I just wanted to
share that with you and and uh thank you
for all the work that you do I will get
off now because I'm hungry and I can
imagine that you are as well and thank
you again for uh sitting here for these
long periods of time
um and so thank you very much
uh thank you very much Janice are are
you willing to take any questions
certainly
uh Janice I do have one
um coming from the North Country myself
our school
District takes kids every year for a
period of nine or so weeks and they ski
at Cannon Mountain one day a week is
that a typical activity done for school
districts in the North country
uh yes we have that program here that's
run by the Eastern Slope ski
um group they raise the money to help
provide that opportunity for students to
go to the ski areas our Public Charter
School went this year it was one of only
two schools that took advantage of it
because of the concern with covet and
the transportation issues that coven put
on public schools SAU 9 has always in
the past uh involved their students it's
a huge program and very very important
thank you very much Janice are there
further questions from the committee
not seeing any hands thank you very much
that's all the people that are wanting
to testify on 148 so with that uh I will
close the hearing on 128 and maybe we
can get a report on how many people
uh it would appear
47 spoke in support 47 in support zero
opposed zero opposed zero neutral zero
neutral
148.
okay so that closes our hearings for
today as I mentioned the beginning no
exact sessions today a lot of food for
thought today and 147 148 and 44.
food for thought thank you so uh thank
you very much everybody for attending
and and getting us so it's now 135 it's
time for lunch